let's turn on my mic um before we get
started with bills I just want to um and
I'm sure the prime sponsor won't mind my
delay cuz it's me
um I want to uh just because it's our
first one of the year and we've got a
new member and we've got some subs I
want to give a a reminder about deorum
of the committee before we get started
we haven't had any issues in this
committee but some other committees have
had some rough patches they've hit um I
want to remind people that we're here to
listen to the public and departments
with regard to the bills before us we're
not here to debate the public on the or
the Departments questions must be
legitimate questions not statements of
your opinion disc disguised as
questions all those testifying will be
treated with respect as your treatment
of those testifying reflects directly on
you your office and this committee
there's a difference between asking a
question and challenging somebody do not
ever challenge members of the public who
took time from their day to be here I
will allow more leeway in questioning
departments or lobbyists as they're
doing their jobs here and they should be
experts on the information they provide
us I will also expect any Department to
testify solely to the facts and
positions not personal opinions and I
expect the complete truth decorum
requires you be recognized before
speaking request a followup if necessary
and address the chair appropriately
don't forget to thank the chair and the
person
testifying failure to adhere to decorum
will result in a warning multiple or
egregious failures to follow of Quorum
may result in you being removed from the
committee no one has a right to be on a
committee it's a privilege and it can be
suspended or
revoked
and
with that I need to explain that the
vice chair will be here today he's just
uh got an appointment that's very
important so he's going to be a little
late and I'm going to be turning over
chair position while I introduce three
bills to the clerk and then uh
representative wette will act as clerk
because the vice chair is missing
um and so I'll let the chair or the the
clerk be the chair and open up the
hearing at his
leisure if you just bear with me for one
minute while I give a quick uh uh
explanation to our fill in clerk
here
all right good morning um I'm going to
open the hearing on HB
11116 and have the prime sponsor begin
his
presentation thank you Mr chair uh for
the record I am representative James
Spain uh and I represent Rockingham
2 1116 is a bill that uh I brought
forward uh as a housekeeping measure
essentially but also uh because of the
the success of the lever action bill
that we passed uh last term so four
years ago um when we introduced that
there was a lot of evidence that we
presented uh on how the lever action
carbine rifle shooting a handgun caliber
was uh safer than a handgun because it
could be directed with more precision
and it was then allowed and uh passed
bipartisan through this committee and
the house to and the Senate and Etc to
uh allow for use of those uh rifles in
areas that were handgun or shotgun only
um I'm not going to get into the
ballistics again but rest assured I can
remind people that the ballistics coming
out of a carbine rifle over those coming
out of the handgun were only about 200
ft per second difference um because of
the the specific pistol calibers we
allowed and at the time it was just 357
44 Magnums and 45 Long CTS that was as a
trial to to see if if uh if it went okay
and if it was uh safe and popular uh
fishing game had a lot of calls and I've
gotten calls and people wanting to try
other calibers um because they don't own
one of these but they are in an area
where it would be beneficial for them to
be able to use a safer gun uh than a
handgun and um so this bill is
essentially uh making a change to the
current law as it as it was signed in uh
last term to uh remove the lever action
part because it doesn't matter if the
rifle is lever action pump action single
shot break open what have you that
doesn't affect the the bullet itself and
we had some people that had some single
shots or uh pump actions and I hadn't
even thought about those because they're
not as popular as the lever action is um
and then in an effort to do
housekeeping um there's another billal
here today that we're going to change
the way the RS a lists all of the
calibers that are permissible for
handgun use in uh in hunting in the
state to make it easier for us to
maintain as new calibers come in um I
don't want to get too deep into that now
but this follows the same pattern as
that other housekeeping Bill and in and
what it's doing is saying that any
straight walled pistol cartridge that's
larger than a 38/357 now the larger than
38/357 is exactly match ing up with the
way the RSA on permissible pistol rounds
will be the fact that we limited it to
straight walled pistol cartridges is a
ballistics issue any bullet that's
necked down has higher velocity a
straight walled pistol cartridge has
lower velocity so in order to keep this
in the safety aspect using these rifles
in the pistol hunting areas we don't
want someone coming in with a
specialized pistol that's a single shot
308 rifle cartridge which technically is
still good for pistol hunting but not in
these areas where it was pistol and
shotgun only for a reason we want it to
be limited to just those straight walled
lower velocity pistol
cartridges um and that's it I can take
any questions if anybody has any but uh
that is the extent of
116 uh thank you representative any
questions from
anyone uh representative
Derby thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question um when we're
talking about changing the actions
allowed from Lever Action to you know
single shop that would include
semi-automatic
um it just says rifle but I don't know
of any semi-automatics that are
chambered in pistol rounds but I I would
assume that yeah I guess semi-automatics
would be in there as well uh mainly it's
meant to address breake opens uh pumps
lever action bolt
action I think that's pretty much it
um follow thank you thank you Mr chair
um have you heard of ARS being um reali
for these um single walled straight
walled um uh pistol rounds no I don't uh
I haven't heard of any ARS being
chambered in a straight walled pistol uh
cartridge uh and I would say that even
if that was the case they still have to
adhere to the uh no more than uh six
rounds and all of this other stuff that
that has to be followed by the regular
pistol hunting rules okay thank
you uh no other questions yep
representative
Harvey so representative Spain you know
my limited knowledge about uh guns and
so forth so I'm going to ask a question
that probably shows that limited
knowledge and hopefully you can help me
with all questions are good questions go
for it so my my question is um
is this um a significant enough gun to
take down an animal a a deer yes um
that's why it's we're we're also saying
38/357 and greater that's currently the
the lowest limit that we're allowed to
use in regular pistol hunting for deer
um and that's why it's it's staying
there and that's the clarification we're
going to make in the rules for the the
other pistol hunting or handgun hunting
section as well where currently every
single caliber is listed out and one of
those is listed incorrectly anyway so it
needs to be cleaned up but yeah okay
thank you so much I appreciate
that uh further
questions um seeing none there's no
other pink cards Mr cheriff I might add
one more thing that I I wanted to
address towards uh representative Darby
because it it comes along with your
question there's nothing in the handgun
hunting area right now that prohibits
semi-automatic handguns either so
semi-automatic handguns if they're in
the appropriate caliber can be used
rather than a revolver say so if you had
a 357 or uh you had a 10 mm you could
use a semi-automatic 10 mm uh in handgun
hunting and it's still allowed but it
has to have only six shots in
it okay seeing no further questions uh
is there any I have no more pink cards
any one wanting to add test testimony
from the back and I don't see any so at
that point I'll close the hearing on
1116 I'll stay right where I am if
that's
okay I I will double check with the with
the real chair uh we're short of our
10:30 schedule time shall we have to
wait yep that's what I thought all right
so we will be on on uh Hiatus here until
10:30
I won't stay in this
chair
all right as we are at uh a little bit
past 10 :30 we're going to uh begin
again and open the hearing on House Bill
1077 and representative Spain
presenting thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee I'm
actually introducing this for the prime
sponsor representative Manion because he
couldn't be here he's sick he and I had
already had a discussion because his
bill does everything that we just talked
about in 116 except mine does more um
his bill uh he when he we don't know why
OS allowed two identical bills to be
drafted okay this is an OS issue his
bill simply changes it from Lever Action
to any action which we just talked about
but it still leaves it to only 35744
Magnum or 45 Colt which we've been
getting calls through fish and game
department and everywhere else and I've
had discussions with Colonel Jordan at
the department and it was the language
of straight wall pistol cartridge came
up in our
conversation um so uh I wanted to make
sure that uh you all knew that this bill
is not really necessary but I'm
introducing it as for representative
Manion and um that's it and I won't take
any questions but I believe there is uh
somebody who else is on the bill to
speak to more about
it uh thank you representative Spain and
we have representative Lily
Walsh thank you Mr chairman for the
record I'm representative Lily Walsh I
represent Rockingham
15 I uh wrote this bill along with uh
representative Manion uh at the request
of a
constituent and I was unaware of uh
chairman Spain's uh bill that actually
covers more so I am in support of his
bill as well and it uh it actually does
a lot more than our bill was that uh we
wrote so that's all I have have to say
uh thank you representative any
questions representative Derby thank you
Mr chair I thank you for taking my
question um Can did the constituent uh
mention what uh you know what caliber or
what uh action uh rifle that they were
interested in
carrying well the point that my
constituent asked for is that any action
uh be allowed and that was that was the
point of writing this
bill
y representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm probably not
asking the right person but um um so you
can tell me that I'm not asking the
right person so I do attend the
legislative sessions with fishing game
and they are opposed to this bill do you
know
why no I'm not aware of
that uh thank thank you representative
Harvey fishing game is not put in a pin
card but if there's anyone that would
like to comment I'm sure we would
welcome that any other
questions all right that being said
fishing game do you have a comment on
that on this bill that you would like to
step forward with just that we you you
probably should come up to the mic if
that would be okay thank
you
yeah red means doesn't mean stuff red
means yeah the full commission um we had
extensive discussions about this and um
basically uh in discussing this bill and
the other bill with representativ plain
we think it would be uh better taken
under a study committee and U Move for
itum study we just have a lot of
concerns about the shotgun only
towns
okay thank you um any further questions
representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so would this be
a bill that would be better um handled
through fish and game rules rather than
here on the legislative
floor um I I really can't answer that
with any degree of
confidence
okay meaning that I'm not sure we have
the authority to address it in roles
okay that that was what I was asking I
didn't say it correctly thank
you representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um can you uh elaborate on the concerns
that the um commission raised about
shotgun only towns well that it should
be the responsibility of the individual
towns uh just to it as it has been in
the
past that was openly discussed and um
appre appreciate representative Harvey
attending and understanding being there
ground floor in the discussion
itself any further
questions all right thank you thank you
thank you for coming
up that being said no further testimony
we'll close the hearing on uh
good
it okay and we'll open here oh we have
to wait sorry sorry sorry thank you
thank you my my helpful fellow
Representatives I appreciate that uh
we're on for the next one for 10:40 so
we have a few minutes to
sit
and might I say you've been doing a
fantastic job this morning very
much um I bring before your committee uh
House Bill 1424 which a housekeeping
bill um and I have an amendment on it
before we even get further into this
because I want to tell you that uh the
intent of this was not to change the
currently allowed calibers for handgun
hunting it was just to list them in our
RSA in an easier to manage way such that
we don't have to go and add more
calibers to the RSA every time another
pistol caliber is developed and to also
at the same time fix the error in the
RSA as it currently is because current
it calls uh to allow for a 50 uh caliber
magnum which doesn't exist the caliber
is actually called a 500 Smith and
Wesson which is a 50 caliber handgun
round that is permissible for hunting
and it was something we added about six
years ago maybe eight because Smith and
Wesson came out with their 50 caliber
handgun however I nobody realized that
we had it listed in the RSA as 50
caliber magnum which doesn't exist it's
actually called a 500 Smith and Wesson
so when I was talking with the fishing
game department and and uh Colonel
Jordan um I had the idea that I said
well what if we just put everything
bigger than this and we'll take the
smallest ethical hunting handgun round
so that anything bigger is is allowable
because it's all ethical for handgun
hunting now keep in mind we're not
talking about designated handgun hunting
zones here this is throughout the whole
state this is just saying if you're
using a handgun instead of a rifle these
are the types of handgun calibers you
can use and uh uh that's why it's called
pistols permitted on the
RSA um any pistol that wasn't listed
here you could not Hunt game with but
every time they came out with something
like the 50 caliber Smith and Wesson
that they call the 500 Smith and Wesson
we had to go and open the law up and add
that to the list so rather than do that
all the time I wrote it this way now if
you look at the original list you'll see
that at the end of the list well not
really even the end of the list near the
end of the list there's something called
a 327 Federal Magnum and because they
listed it out of order it wasn't lower
than the 357
Magnum um I left it off by mistake
because anything it says any caliber 38
or 357 and greater and obviously 327 is
smaller than 38 357 so it would have
been suddenly illegal to use that and
we've allowed people to do it all this
time we didn't want to leave that off so
my Amendment says uh 327 Federal Magnum
and any caliber 38/357 and greater
simple change just to make sure we don't
exclude that one that we've always
allowed people to hunt with but we
didn't want to say that was the smallest
because there are calibers between 327
and 357 that are not suitable for
handgun um mainly because they don't
have a lot of power even if they've got
a larger bullet right taking the game
depends not only on the size of the
bullet but the amount of
um foot pounds that you deliver
downrange the the amount of force that
it hits the animal with and
um so we didn't want to accidentally end
up with people hunting with a round that
was not uh suitable such as a
35 um or
something you need to have that 38 357
is the minimum but we'll still allow the
327 and so that's that I'll take any
questions if anybody has any
representative Harvey so this is another
one that the fishing game has opposed do
you know why yes actually um I got a
call from the director and he said and I
will tell you originally The Fish and
Game Commission was in was uh supportive
of this and actually uh the department
was the one that I worked out the
language with and the director called me
he said I'm extremely sorry but the
commission came down and said they don't
want to talk about any of these um gun
bills in an election
year that's what I heard so um the
department is not against this they
actually asked for it we do have to fix
the 50 caliber mistake that's in the law
anyway and we want to make it easier to
maintain this list going forward by not
having to list every single caliber
that's allowed and um so as with many
bills in the past we've had a vote from
the commission where the majority of the
Commissioners and I'm not sure if every
commissioner was unanimous on it but a
majority of them decided let's just kill
all the gun bills this
year so that's my
understanding any other questions yeah
any further questions uh representative
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um would this uh
include a 38 special and do you think
that a 38 special is um suitable for
deer hunting
no it would not it would be a 38 a
regular
38357 a 38 special specifically has to
have the word special next to it because
it's a shorter powder
cartridge okay um can follow up um thank
you Mr chair very naive question how how
in the law would um 38 357 not include
um 38 special because it's it's anything
at that caliber so let me explain to you
if if I said that you could use a 22
long rifle for something you would not
be able to use a 22 short which is the
same round but only it's really tiny you
wouldn't be able to use a 22 um Magnum
which is much bigger if we said
specifically 22 long rifle the 38
Special is a specific cartridge if you
go and buy 38 Special
they're not going to be the same size as
a standard
38 and it's designated that way
purposefully so if we wanted to include
38 Special we would have to specifically
include the word special in here after
38 to make sure it was included the same
as our laws for hunting uh with a 22 uh
typically say 22 long rifle to exclude
the 22
short uh any further
questions uh seeing none we will close
the hearing
on
14:24 thank you
committee
so as a reminder we're not on till 11:00
so we're uh in in take a break till
11:
okay I'm going to open the hearing on HB
1024 and I'm going to recognize
representative Brian Cole the prime
sponsor to present his Bill thank you Mr
chairman committee's a fishing
game so uh constituent brought me this
bill and uh as I researched it air
rifles have come a long way in evolution
it's kind of like the evolution of a gun
it's no longer a pel gun
these air rifles like out in the Africa
and the Amazon they'll take down a water
buffalo now they're that
powerful and so we wanted to legalize
them for hunting up here in New
Hampshire but we wanted to do it kind of
like in baby
steps so when I originally wrote it you
know we have such a long window at OLS
to write a bill so I got the bill in and
then we worked on it so we came up with
this
amendment and we separated the calibers
between small game and large game we
defined
it then we also wanted to make it so the
fishing game could roll it out in zones
so that's why we put the language in the
last sentence there so they can kind of
test Market it but what I'm kind of
asking you to do is to interim study
this because we still have to do some
testing on the air rifles I want to
prove The lethality of them make sure
it's ethical and taking an animal here
in New Hampshire so get everyone
together I'm not going to be able to do
that until probably Springtime so that's
what I'm requesting this committee to do
with this bill at this
time sorry open any questions if you
have anything about
it Mr clerk uh thank you Mr chair uh
thank you representative Cole for taking
my question who who's going to be doing
the
testing uh we found Sig firearms in
eping they're going to allow us to use
their range and then we have a
manufacturer who's developing he's
already developed up to 50 caliber air
rifles so we want to get together with
fishing game we want to get together
with the other commissions bring them
down there take like ballistics gel and
S the penetration of the Round And The
lethality of the weapons to make sure
like I said it's ethical and taking game
thank
you representative
wette thank you for taking my question
is there any plans or are there any
plans from the manufacturers to um be
part of the Pitman Robertson Act of
conservation that the rest of the uh
firearm manufacturers in this country
are part of that had came up in this in
thank you again to the chairman for
pointing this out to me that's why we're
allowing a fee to be charged if you want
to use an air rifle so it'll cover that
fee if and when they do put that into
law in the federal law so the fishing
game will have money to pay those fees
and then it'll come
back representative Harvey than thank
you Mr chair thank you um for taking my
question so um I I think I heard so
you're testing for just tell me what
you're testing for because I'm not sure
if I heard it correctly if I go say a 30
odd 6 is a typical caliber to take a
deer down we want to make sure that the
air rifle that's a caliber 30 caliber
has the same velocity same penetration
same impact and killing power as a as a
you know around with powder in it so the
word you were using was lethality not
legality no lethality yes yes we want to
make sure it's a nice clean kill for the
animal and there's no suffering right y
I think I just
misheard representative Khan thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
taking my question um you mentioned that
uh that uh you tried to introduce this
in New Hampshire and yeah rifle game a
long way in these days is very powerful
can you tell us what other state already
using this you know legally I'm not
aware of any other states thank
you if the chair can jump in I believe
Colorado allows it uh and I'm getting a
nod from fishing game so um at least
Colorado and and there may be Montana as
well but I don't know for sure um that
might be a question for fishing game
when they testify okay thank you
representative
perir thank you for taking my question
um are we if you haven't even tested
this uh uh air rifle yet are we jumping
the gun with passing taking this bill up
now should we wait a year and do it
after you've done the testing that's why
I'm asking I'm recommending interm study
until we've performed the test and then
you'll have your answer you don't want
to just pull it um and not no I don't
see any reason to we've come this far
with it the Final Phase is basically
testing it making sure it does what it
says it's going to
do okay thank
you representative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um in the study um as I look a little
into um air rifles it appears that the
slug that these shoot come in come in
different grains different weights and
it um
would the study uh evaluate different
grains and how those might be sort of
permitted I requested all the ballistics
information on the rare FAL for each
caliber be given so yeah all information
will be available thank you
yep any other questions for the
sponsor seeing none thank you so much
today thank you thank you
committee and the chair will now
recognize Colonel George from fishing
game who's asked for two
minutes good morning and uh chairman
Spain and members of the House fishing
game resources nice to be in front of
you again there's some new faces so
welcome hopefully we uh we will be on
good terms throughout the session that's
what we that's what I hope for so I was
thrown into this bill I wasn't a uh the
prime person to represent our the
Department's opinion but I'm here to
represent the commission's position and
the commission took the position of
opposition to this but they did that
basically I think for some of the re and
we oppose it we the staff Wildlife staff
and law enforcement for a lot of the
reasons that we're already talking about
um I think and it's just my we're
concerned about ethical killing uh we
want to make sure that we don't put
something out there that people will
lose animals with um we are concerned
about air pressures calibers what
happens when you load these things in a
warmed environment and then go out into
the cold does it still high will it have
the killing capacity that it had in and
I don't we don't know the answers to any
of those so interim study made good
sense to take a look at it and attend
the testing of it to see um I'm not
going to say that we would be willing to
change our opinion but we certainly are
willing to open-minded enough to see the
testing and to see if it is something
that can be used I don't know of any
issue with using it as far as law
enforcement goes as long as we don't get
into um you know into a situ ation where
we in the field are going to have to
test the rifles I don't know how we
would do that so we have to be confident
I think uh that these things will do
what they say they will do um the
license fee came in kind of after our
vote so we hadn't taken a position on
that so I think the commission and I
don't there are commission members here
but I think they are open to considering
looking at it studying it and then
rendering an opinion after we see
that are there any questions for the
colonel um actually let me start out
with a couple if I might Colonel Jordan
sure did you get a chance to see the
amendment I did okay um I worked with
the Prime on this because there were a
lot of errors in the original as you can
imagine they even had turkeys included
in there which is just a non-starter
yeah um the Pitman Robertson act not
giving any money to fishing game um made
me more likely to recommend that fish
and game be allowed to create a tag for
this much the muzzle loader tag would
the department have a problem with a tag
that provides extra income law
enforcement wouldn't I don't know I
can't speak for the commission because I
don't know that we put that before them
but I don't I don't know why they would
oppose that as long as we can operate it
uh and it can be done in our business
division as just an additional tag
similar to what we've done with other
tags we we are doing that now so I would
assume we could do that but I I don't
want to tell you the commission's good
with it because I haven't run it before
them fair enough and a followup to uh
would be the question that was asked
earlier about other states do you know
of any others besides of Colorado please
the only one I know of is Colorado but I
haven't I haven't gone online and looked
at that I know Colorado uses it and
they've had they've not had any reported
issues that I could find so um so I
don't but I don't know of any other
state thank you any questions for the
colonel representative Ford you have yet
to speak today go for it thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking my
question sure
how how how long should this study or
study or Research into the air rifles
would you feel confident and confident
enough to say like yes pass this bill
we've tested it and we're good to go how
long that's a great question I think if
all of our concerns are addressed things
like ballistics changing temperatures
what happens when the pressure
drops um you know how much of a change
does that make all of those things when
all of those questions are answered um I
would say that we would be comtable I
will tell you this I will be very vocal
if we're not comfortable if we still
have issues I would be concerned about
that cuz what we don't want I don't
think is wounded animals running around
the the state or people getting injured
I am I'm fairly confident personally
fairly confident that the manufacturers
can answer those questions if we give
them the opportunity I just want to see
it we want to see it and I'd like to
present that to our commission
afterwards and and if everybody's on
board with it and those questions have
been answered um that's a that's a tough
question question to ask um but we want
to be satisfied it will do the job that
we're asking it to do and if they do
that we'd be good with it I
think any further questions
representative Darby thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question yes
sir um are there any uh concerns about
um night hunting or poaching um since
this would you know the this has much uh
the noise from this would be much much
less right and I didn't see any in in
this amendment or the original Bill any
adjustment to the night hunting standard
in terms of you know what qualifies
for C you know for night hunting so
that's a good question as well and uh at
the risk of getting slapped by many
older wardens who would have a very
different opinion who I worked with for
years those days have kind of gone away
and I'll tell you why they have uh
people are using night vision today
which is something we never thought we'd
see they do it routinely they are using
they can use silencers I fought that in
this committee very hard because I felt
that that was going to increase uh the
the ability for some to poach and maybe
it does um but I've also found that
prior to that and after that people use
silencers anyway the poachers will do
this anyway um we we fought hard I
remember years and years ago against
crossbows thinking the same thing people
will go out at night excuse me and use a
cross
again I those are are fears that I don't
want to say didn't occur cuz I think
they did but it didn't do it in the
numbers that I predicted it would uh
which is was embarrassing frankly so I
thought it would triple it and it didn't
I think there is a mindset that these
particular individuals um you know we
made cases recently where they were
using all kinds of Technology that's
never reached this committee yet that
will that's pretty scary so I don't know
that it would increase that
um it may answer it may answer some
issues we have in some of our more urban
areas where gunshots go off and frighten
people because I get a lot of calls
about that even though hunting is one of
the safest Sports you can and we can
prove that um people are concerned they
hear it go off so I don't know maybe
this would address some of that in some
of the more congested areas so I I think
it could go either way but I don't see
it personally I don't see it increasing
poaching from where we are poaching is
Alive and Well by the way way I just
want to tell the committee we made 59 n
hunting cases last fall that's
unbelievable that's a lot of night
hunting cases our technology has
improved quite frankly our officers are
better at it than I ever was I think
they're they're a little more Savvy on
the technology but it just told me that
it's alive and well yeah good work
thanks representative
AAR thank you Mr chairman and once again
welcome to the committee thank you very
much um
this question is not for the officer but
um a comment to the commission is that
allowed I would ask you to hold that uh
if the commission comes up to discuss we
would uh go ahead and welcome that um
question for the commission uh comments
wouldn't be something we would do during
the
testimony um any other questions for the
colonel uh thank you Mr chair Mr clerk
sorry I had my mic off thank you uh
welcome Colonel nice to see you thank
you sir good to see you um can you for
me elaborate a little bit more on what I
asked uh representative Cole about the
makeup of who's doing the testing are
are is fishing aim going to be
intimately involved in this testing
process or as an observer probably more
as an observer I would hope that it that
we would be I would expect and hope that
we will be able to have input on it but
no we the we would leave this to the
manufacturers to demonstrate their
prodct thank you and I can add to that I
was working with the prime sponsor on
making sure he could set this up David
czy isn't with Sig anymore right if you
remember he was one of the ones behind
the suppressor bill that I was
co-sponsor of um so we've got a
different contact over there but we
would indeed open this not only to the
fish and game but uh you know not
everybody at fish and game but a few a
few of you right sure um but the
commission I believe would be invited as
well for anyone who wanted to come and
see it I think that would be important
to do that yeah absolutely yeah um and
that would allow for Hands-On yes as
well so that everyone could have the
experience of of firing the the air gun
and bringing their concerns to bringing
their concerns to the manufacturer and
the range operators and uh witnessing
firsthand the penetration in the
ballistic gelatin and all that right uh
and I think that's just responsible to
do any further questions seeing none
thank you very
much
the commission will now call or
recognize or the the committee will now
recognize Fred Bud bird bird
sorry thank you Mr chairman good morning
ladies and gentlemen appreciate the
opportunity to uh comment on this bill
uh my name is Fred bird I'm the
assistant manager for the north eastern
states for the Congressional Sportsman
Foundation I manage uh Maryland North I
am a New Hampshire resident and active
Sportsman and uh prior straford County
Commissioner for fishing game
representing 137,000 constituents um for
many of the reasons that have already
been articulated our main reason uh
we're recommending amendments this is a
great opportunity for Access uh but for
the pr dollars now I we will let you
know last year uh the state uh through
Pitman Robinson and in combination with
license sales saw $24.5 million come to
the the agency the state fishing game to
help uh run the agency that's a pretty
big number obviously the concern is with
this passing and without that you've
heard a couple times a tag an air gun
tag um if if Sportsmen and women decided
to go the way of the air gun and and
leave their other uh already excise tax
Firearms we could lose out on that $7.2
million from
PR um I would also like to call to your
attention I I did not know that there
was was an amended version I I was going
to I didn't want to interrupt you but I
was going to ask if you'd like to see a
copy that would be fantastic one of my
uh representative Mooney can you pass
yeah thank
you there were a number of concerns
addressed by the amendment such as the
hunting of turkeys because there aren't
any air shotguns out that I know of
right now and um so that would just be a
non-starter but also the uh the the
range of calibers did not fit for all
game uh we literally would not want
somebody shooting um you know uh rabbits
with um a water buffalo sure right shot
nor would we want somebody shooting um
the deer with something that's too small
so it's divided up that's exactly right
and to that point Mr chairman um you
know we would recommend that the
authority remain with the department and
the commission to to allow for that rule
making obviously you know to your point
we don't want to blow up rabbits with
large calibers but also allowing for
those small game calendars calibers 22
1.77 to do do that small game cuz they
they are uh ethical and the effect the
efficiency of those rounds are more than
enough for small game and obviously
allowing that range uh and I agree with
you in the concern of the Turkey um I do
know that California allows for air guns
on Turkey um for those that are
unfamiliar uh we have the authorized
loads in the state of New Hampshire that
are shotgun loads and the load comes out
in a conical shape to envelop the head
of the turkey the soft fleshy part of
the turkey this is for an effective
lethal kill of a wild turkey turkeys
feather make up the body doing body
shots with a a shotgun load or in this
case a small caliber air rifle just
doesn't is not effective it's built like
Kevlar and largely bounces off the bird
so we want to make sure that if we're
out there harvesting that we do it
quickly ethically and and honor the
animal um because a lot of this has been
already taken care of with the
Amendments I did want to answer some of
the the commission's um questions as as
it pertains to other states if you
would feel free okay very good um in
2019 in Georgia by way of Senate Bill 72
and in Virginia by way of House Bill
1393 and Senate Bill
5859 uh legislation was enacted to
authorize uh the use of air guns in
2022 the Utah Governor Spencer Cox
signed Senate Bill 205 to allow air guns
and then uh in 2022 Oklahoma author R by
way of 7 uh 1571 Senate Bill the use of
air a Aero air guns uh essentially in
the same makeup of air gun so uh and
then to the Colonel's Point Colorado as
I understand and Montana do the same
thing so there is there is case out here
there there has been legislation passed
all across the country for this and with
the right measures and the right testing
that that's proved positive for this
this body um I think this is something
we can move forward with
amendments
thank you for your testimony any
questions yes
sir Mr
clerk thank you Mr chairman would you
more slowly tell me the name of your
organization because I couldn't write
that quickly yeah sorry about that
Congressional Sportsman's Foundation we
represent 50 uh National Assembly of
Sportsman's caucuses we have uh
organizations in all 50 states thank you
yes
sir any other
questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for your time and I
have no more pink cards so uh is there
anybody who has not had a chance to
speak that wants to add to testimony
today seeing none we're going to close
the public hearing on
1024 HB
1024 we have a short break before we
start the next one I believe actually
we're going to break for lunch the next
one one's not till 1 so everybody can
have a fantastic lunch and be back for
1:00 22 States 22 States so we have a
lot of new people in here and not they
don't
know sure we can do that right before we
start again yeah it has something to you
know it's important and it's it's why I
made I made sure that the prime sponsor
put in a tag situation I said because
this isn't going to apply the vice chair
and I discussed this it was one of the
things we said straight out is you know
this has to we're not getting any money
for Pitman Robertson so we need to let
the department charge right so but it's
not won't quite be the same because
you're only getting money for one tag
unless you make it's true but the
department does that um just basically
to make sure that they are able to find
fund things that have to do with that
particular I get that but it's not quite
the same but anyway I just wanted
to
for
e
1:00 is
for
lower SL
more
for
hello hello got a thank you very
much
okay I'm going to call the hearing on
hb1 1228 to
order and uh recognize representative
Claudine Burnham the prime sponsor of
the
bill to introduce it
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee for hearing uh hb1 1228 I do
have an amendment which I will speak
about as well uh hopefully you have
received a
copy so hb1 1228 is a means to help
alleviate some issues that guides
applicants have encountered while trying
to achieve their guides
license although guides licensing
procedures fall under the
responsibilities of Fishing Game
Commission the procedures examinations
and other requirements currently are the
responsibility of the executive director
as an applicant proceeds to complete his
or her examinations the applicant must
also complete an oral examination which
is typically conducted by members of
local guides Association members and not
necessarily fishing game law enforcement
unfortunately this procedure tends to be
received with bias response by
applicants according to the fishing um
sorry according to the New Hampshire
fishing game website a guide applicant
must have working knowledge of the
listed topics to be successful with
exams
knowledge New Hampshire fishing game
laws pertaining to the taking possession
and transportation of fish and or
Wildlife to the state in the state of
New Hampshire New Hampshire fishing game
laws pertaining to current bag limits on
fish and or wildlife in the state of New
Hampshire Federal Regulations pertaining
to taking possession and transportation
of wildlife general knowledge of fish
and or wildlife management practices in
the state of New Hampshire general
knowledge of fish and or Wildlife Cycles
knowledge of the laws pertaining to
guides and their
clients general knowledge of the State
of New Hampshire geography General
knowled of the Flora and Fauna of the
state knowledge of emergency first aid
and CPR general knowledge of voting
rules and regulations available through
the department of safety Marine Division
under the section guide resource list on
the website States applicants must be
ready to identify various animals birds
and fish found in New Hampshire and have
knowled general knowledge as it relates
to their biology other questions will be
asked regarding safety all watercraft
regulations handling of boats canoes
kayaks watercraft technology rescue
techniques aids to navigation navigation
rules and maps in compass in addition
hunting guide applicants must possess a
valid hunter safety certification and a
current hunting license fishing guide
applicants utilizing motorboats are
required to have a a commercial boat
operator license from marine patol and
fishing
license the following materials that can
be utilized to study these uh for to
become a guide and becoming licensed in
New Hampshire are the following New
Hampshire hunting and fishing laws
digest or laws annotated and FIS New
Hampshire off-highway recreational
vehicle law digest the boers guide of
New Hampshire USDA guide permits Forest
Service fact sheet
migratory bird hunting regulations
outsmart Outback to First Aid Pro
procedures and back country skills
fishes of New Hampshire by John scarola
the Peterson's field guides staying
found the complete map Encompass
handbook by Jane Fleming the essential
wild wilderness Navigator by Dave SE
seedman National aabon pocket guides L
Master method of water flow
identification birds of North America
and MC River guide llbean guide to
canoeing by Ken Stone River Rescue by
Leo betel and slim Ray the outdoor
leadership handbook by Gil gilpatrick be
an expert with map and Compass by Bourn
killstorm you are alone in the main
Woods The Lost Hunter guide so according
to the FIS
130103 in applications and procedures
each applicant must then take and Su
successfully pass both a written and
oral examination administered
at the fishing game department the
written examination requires a passing
grade of at least 75% or
better once an applicant passes the
written examination the applicant May
attend an oral examination within the
following 12 months should the applicant
fail the oral examination the applicant
will be denied the license just one part
which is the oral examination and I
believe that you're going to hear some
testimony on this today because for all
of this information which the applicant
must find themselves it is not given to
them in a curriculum to study to have
knowledge of and all rests on one oral
examination
question the oral examination is a pass
or fail and the tests the applicants
practical skills knowledge and abilities
and hunting for a hunting guide license
or fishing for a fishing guide license
however should the applicant fail this
oral examination the applicant is given
no reason or answer for failing the
result no
answer you take all this time to study
to read the required reading materials
to get your licensing to pursue
something as a guide and it depends on
this one oral question pass or
fail there is no detailed report on what
the applicant did to fail which does not
allow the applicant further knowledge of
what was said incorrectly or how to even
learn from the incorrect
response this or examination process is
conducted by at least
two and no more than three examiners of
which two members may be active or
retired conservation officers from the
the fishing game law enforcement
Division and one currently licensed
hunting or fishing
guide
guide chosen by the executive director
or
designate unfortunately this is where
many applicants find themselves in
Conflict when the guide providing the
oral examination question may also be a
guide in the area the applicant is
interested in achieving a guide's
license for instance you have a
business I want
to open a business just like
yours but you get to determine whether I
can open my business that's just like
yours that's kind of like the same idea
I
think any applicant unsuccessful in
passing the written exam may be allowed
to retest at the next available date
scheduled by the department but in no
event sooner than 60 days from the date
of the original
examination 2 months seems a bit too
long to retake an exam hunting and
fishing are
seasonal we're asking them to wait
longer than necessary in my opinion hb1
1228 recommends no less than two weeks
according to FIS 130 01 applications and
procedures the application of a person
failing a second written or oral
examination shall be Deni denied in
writing subject to the right of the
applicant to seek an appeal of the
decision why should applicants have
limited attempts lastly the current
requirement that no person who has
failed a second written or oral
examination shall be approved to sit for
practical skills Examination for a
period of 1 year from the date of the
second failed
examination why so long a whole year
perhaps a month would suffice hunting
and fishing are limited to Seasons a
year and holding an applicant from
preceding these requirements just seems
like a method to keep potential guides
from being licensed within the same
districts as current guides that are
providing the
examinations hb1 1228 also speaks to the
license renewal requirement in RSA TW uh
25.4 that currently states that every
resident 65 years of age or older who
has been a license guide in the state
for five or more years May obtain a
license as a guide to fish or to hunt by
payment of only the cost of issuing said
license as determined by the executive
director why is a guide provided such
accommodations and why does the
executive director get to determine the
cost or no cost to the resident how is
that
determined New Hampshire has a the most
rigorous requirements for applicants to
become a guide and little information to
assist the applicant with a study guide
or curriculum nearby states such as
Massachusetts and Rhode Island have no
fees or tests Connecticut requires a
$100 license fee each year and no test
is required New York also has a $100 fee
for a 5-year license written exam with a
pass of 70% or better and all
information and curriculum on the test
is free for studying purposes
Maine requires $100 per classification
initial fee $135 for fiveyear license
not every year and a written and oral
exam requiring a 70% or better and all
information in curriculum is available
online and clearly stated in the
following oral Board Test a specific
outline 14 days to take retake written
in 30 days to retake the oral board and
as a result main guide schools have a 90
to 95% pass rate HB 1228 establishes a
five person committee to steer the
guides licensed qualifications versus to
burden on one individual currently the
executive director by having a committee
com comprised of only active or retired
conservation officers from the fish and
game law enforcement division as members
applicants may receive a broader scope
of what is required to know and learn in
order to achieve a successful grade on
the written and oral exams the Amendment
20241 77h states that members of this
committee shall not currently or have
formerly been guides this is to
eliminate any possible Notions of
biasness that is currently reflected on
today's applicants by this process I ask
that you support and accept Amendment
d177
and pass HB 1228 with Amendment so we
can expand the fishing games guides
program with a more fair and transparent
approach to testing future applicants
and growing our guides program with
skillful fishing and hunting guide
guides thank you for consideration I do
have copies of my testimony if you would
like them I pass them around any
questions thank you representative um if
you can give your copy of your written
testimony to to uh the clerk at the very
least that will help out if you want to
pass them out that's fine as well are
there any questions does anybody in the
committee have questions representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair and uh thank
thank you for taking my question so um I
I've I've not hired a guide but my
husband has hired many guides and
oftentimes he ends up with these guides
in very um remote areas is so I'm
wondering why you wouldn't
support um a rigorous
um
um a rigorous um outline of studies if
indeed these guides are taking people
and their lives at risk into very um you
know Outback type country um I I heard
your testimony about other states but
that makes me just a little nervous I'm
just if you could expand on that please
sure no I am um not opposed to rigorous
uh requirements as a matter of fact I
think that everyone should be certified
as a CPR and first aid um individual uh
just having knowledge to me in in those
far outreaches to me wouldn't be
acceptable but it is only knowledgeable
and that's why I really stress that um
so I'm not opposed to that I I
shared um other
local or nearby States their testing
procedures or what those qualifications
are in comparison to what New Hampshire
has because um information as to what is
expected for a guide is provided more so
than just a list of books and uh
materials that a guide needs to find on
their
own further
questions representative
Paige thank you so if I if I understand
your testimony correctly it sounds like
either you are alleging or have you you
have heard others allege that there is
bias among the examiners my and also
that they're not seeing the results of
the oral
examination are you aware of
documentation of that oral examination
that exists and are um to substantiate
those allegations and are those publicly
available after the examination upon
request like through a right to no
request or such thank you for your
question um I'm not aware of any
documentation especially on the oral
examination because it is an oral
question um however I do believe you'll
hear testimony from those who have
experienced
that and vice chair goalie thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the
question was I correct in hearing you
say Maine does an oral interview I'm
sorry can you repeat the
question was I correct in hearing that
you stated Maine does a written as well
as oral correct
follow follow
up do you know if after the oral
interview in Maine if they are provided
if they fail a reason why through the
oral interview I do not know that
one last follow
up so I guess my question is so main
could be doing well it sounds good that
they're doing a written and an
oral comparing them to New Hampshire
saying they're better off by doing the
process the way they do it really might
not be the truth if they have a
subjective oral interview same way New
Hampshire
does can I answer that kind of question
um so I'm not saying that Maine is
better I'm just kind of expressing what
the other states are have been doing and
and how they conduct their exams and
their fee
process thank you any further
[Music]
questions representa Ford representative
Ford thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question just real quick on
the amendment it says that the committee
uh the fish Game Commission
the guide committee should be only of
active or retired conservation officers
and I I'm just wondering would you be
open to having someone from like uh the
New Hampshire guides Association on this
particular um committee and not just
conservation officers recognizing they
are guides and they may not be in the
same business I love your analogy I
really appreciate it um but they would
understand what it means to become a
guide and could give insights that maybe
a conservation officer may not
necessarily have would you be open to
adding those with experience as a guide
on this particular committee um so the
amendment does specifically State on
line seven the members of the committee
shall not currently be or have forly
been guides that's the purpose of this
amendment unfortunately was in the
original bill and I wanted to make sure
that that was clear my understanding is
that um it would be preferred not
perhaps they could be advisory but not
NE necessarily on the
Committees follow up and from your point
of view what is the what's the benefit
or the loss both actually what's the
benefit and what's the loss of not
having someone who is a former or
current guide on the on the commission
or on the committee sorry so I am not um
a hunter or Fisher but I do support them
I have family members that are um and I
understand where um they are in this
position it's a tight community
and I think that
um there tends to
be maybe
misunderstanding and just to avoid that
kind of um misunderstanding or
biasness um it would be better for the
committee not to have a representative
of the guides
Association representative
Morton thank you Mr chair and thank you
thank you for taking my question
um the amendment does state that you'd
like the committee to be comprised only
of active and retire or retired
conservation officers from Fish and Game
law enforcement division as the members
did you consult with fish and game about
that and do they feel like they have
enough active and retired members who
have time to be on this committee I have
[Music]
not any further
questions uh representative goalie Vice
chair goalie thank you Mr chair and just
one last question on the
amendment do you know if any of the
other states you cited in their testing
process have requirements that no member
of their c um testing Community
is any guide cannot participate in this
process I'm not familiar with their
process as far as a committee or who is
in um direct contact with providing that
those
resources um it's
just I think this might be a suitable
process to alleviate any um supposed
bias and have more transparency and
oversight and a um a committee
where um applicants can come to a
meeting to address certain situations
that may
occur thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony today thank
you the chair will recognize now
representative Glenn Bailey who's asked
for less than three
minutes yeah I actually had her next
anyway so if you'd like to switch places
we can do that representative Penza
who's asked for two
minutes so I was made aware of this
issue from uh representative Claudine
Burnham and then uh spoke with a few
members in my county in straford county
that this is affected so I think we're
reading into this bill a lot this
doesn't change the requirements the
rigorous standards or anything like that
I think full transparency is important
telling people you know they don't the
other states by the way do have um they
do provide study materials and things
like that that we don't so we're giving
them a list and we're asking them to
just go out and get those things um when
you fail a test if you don't have any
idea how you failed it that's just
ridiculous so that fixes this um there's
one person right now that is that is in
charge of this and so having a committee
um it's so we have and the transparency
of it is if you have someone that's in
the gues business it is a very small
community you have to be very careful
about you know they're going of course
they're going to want to pick the
winners and the losers too because they
don't want to have necessarily that
competition so I think this levels the
playing field it offers transparency and
I think that's just what's needed
because there's one person right now
that is making these decisions so mind
you this wasn't we didn't want to have
to P put a bill in uh we tried to fix
this another way and we didn't get
anywhere and so that is why this bill is
forward so and I have to go testify on
another bill but uh if you have any
questions um you know I can take a
couple but this is this is really just
fixing a fixing a problem and a little
bit of an injustice to some people that
have been really trying to um to get
this
license any questions representative
Harvey so um I I hear what you're saying
basically what they're pres providing is
a syllabus a list of um material where
the questions might come from but not a
list of the questions and you know
that's all of us have gone through high
school and and Beyond and and that's
kind of what you get as a syllabus why
is why are you suggesting it should be
different than for an organization that
takes people's lives into their hands I
didn't suggest that at all I I suggested
a study guide doesn't give the answers
to the questions so she gave you the
laundry list of everything that you
would need to know specifically if you
are going to uh get this licensing and I
think that's fine but uh you know an
outline would be nice I'm not asking for
the answers to the
questions representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you said that um
you've I talked to some people that were
um you know grieved by the existing
process say which um which kind of what
type of guides were they freshwater
hunting saltwater they're here so
they're going to I want them to speak to
how they were
thanks representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you just clarify you said
there's only one person in charge of it
now is that referring to the oral board
decision no that's referring to the
executive director okay thank you that's
all any other questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony and good
luck with your next
bill the chair now recognizes
representative Glenn
Bailey thank you Mr chairman and
esteemed committee members uh I know
nothing about fishing game um I I've
heard some of the same complaints and
and I would I guess my expertise you
call it that is I've spent three years
on Edna representative goalie can verify
that and we seem to spend a considerable
amount of time with boards and licenses
and there's been a trend over the last
couple of years of separating the board
from the
licensing well the board provides the
knowledge of what should be known and
what should be tested and the licensing
is done by
oplc and he can confirm that for me but
we were warned at one point about there
was a particular license that only had
30 people in the whole state had the
license and there was seven of them were
on the board you know and in in a
rotation it's like well the same 30
people rotate through the board every
three or four years you know it gets to
be a little incestuous you might say and
they were warned that they were in
danger of a
lawsuit that it was so closed and so
particular to
the choice of those people as to who
would be next to be on this license they
were just warned that there was a
potential there for a serious lawsuit
and I kind of wonder if maybe some of
that is rearing its head here from what
I heard from some people who were
attempting to get
licensed is it gets to be so it's an
oral exam and they won't tell you what
you did wrong and then you have to take
it again and they won't tell you what
you did wrong so you do it wrong again
it gets to be a little
hinky uh that's all I just I would
advise you to take a look at that aspect
and maybe consider separating them like
every other license in the state is
trending thank you thank you for your
testimony are you open to questions
certainly does anybody have any
questions representative peir thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
just to be clear you talked about a some
board that was uh admonished that they
were expecting a lawsuit that is not not
anything wait a minute that's not
anything relative to fish and game oh no
it wasn't fishing it was just it's just
the style of Licensing you know there's
a there's a trend to to be a certain way
the board is one thing and the knowledge
is one thing this began to sound I don't
think brain surgeons have it as
difficult as fishing game
gues
uh you might want to consider whether
that's too
much thank you again for your testimony
any other
questions seeing none thank
you thank you m
chairman chair will now recognize Dave
[Music]
P representing the New Hampshire guides
Association if you do have um your
testimony as it says here I would
appreciate you passing that out and
please don't read from your
testimony right we've got it here in
front of us thank you thanks my name is
David P I am here representing the the
hon guides Association and for those of
you that read that written testimony I
am principally since Co the guides
Association representative to the uh to
the
uh board that does the the group that
does
evaluation so if you would believe all
of this I'm the person that's trying to
stop other guides from being
guides um if you read the testimony that
that that I gave that's incorrect um and
I and the other the I can't say it vly
enough but I'm not going to repeat
myself that is not the intent um what I
would bring to the uh to the committee's
attention is that um the board of
electric
rans is I'm Car electrical licensed so I
have a little bit of background this one
um the board of electricians is three
licensed electricians two from the
public and the fire and a representative
of the fire Marshall's office every time
you take the test the application fee is
$60 the exam is $50 and a r test is
$25
so electricians testing electricians or
certainly providing the information for
that
um main Wildlife it's I don't want to
Discount the uh sponsor testimony but
it's not $100 it's
$125 and it's
$125 for each classification so if you
apply for Hunting Fishing those are all
$125 every
time every time you retake the failed
oral exam it's
$125 their their committee
their evaluators are made out of are
made up
of
wardens members of of the guide
community and members of what would be
fishing game here it's uh DMR I believe
in Maine so they have a very similar
setup as to what we
have the issue that so I have been as in
that in that written testimony I've been
involved in this since the since we I've
been a guide since 2005 drive from the
fire service in 2007 and I've been
involved in this process since that proc
from from that point
onward
originally uh and and to dat there is no
cost to taking a test the guides test in
the state of New Hampshire what that has
evolved into is people don't have any
skin in the game so and and I will say
as a matter of background there are not
30 there's anywhere between 150 and 200
Li license guides in state of New
Hampshire depending on what year it is
and what time of year it is um and of
that there are probably I can count less
than 20 that make their living at
guiding and I put myself in the the rest
are it's a hobby
we found something we love to do and we
do it um but it is not our primary way
of making a living so given that fact
that people come to this test and I will
tell you from a lot of years of being an
evaluator they come to this test totally
totally unprepared and that has resulted
in a a tremendous amount of folks that
just don't get past the first Iota now
for those of you that took Hunter Ed you
spent 30 minutes learning how to orient
a map and find North
right that is one of the
questions and I can't tell you
accurately but I can tell you that of
the last group three of them
failed now if you're going to go out in
the woods with somebody wouldn't you
want them to be able to orient a map and
use a magnetic
compass so that those are the kinds of
things that that I find um being issues
so not having that investment and not
having a
a financial impact when I took my
electrician's Li license test that I was
going to make a living that's how I was
going to feed my family guiding is not
who having ever intended to feed my
family and some many thinks are going to
guide for a living and and feed their
family a lot is probably
mistaken um and as far as the uh the
oral exam I am not sure the colonel can
certainly speak to whether it's uh
discoverable uh through right to know um
and it's a personal record I'm not sure
how that would work if it is if if it is
available uh you'll be surprised I will
tell you that so again I came from the
fire service side everything we do is
based on an oral
exam
and those were very subjective oral
exams if you made a mistake you could be
taken down a bad
Road this oral exam we fishing game
chose early and we have maintained this
is this is structured this is not a
single question that you fail this is a
series of questions that have assigned
grades now the incident
changes but the grades stay the same
throughout so it is not an arbitrary
Dave P decided I don't like your color
your eyes you're going to become a
fishing guide you're going to become I
have to be a fly fishing
guide somebody comes in we need guides
we cannot we have never been in a
position where we had enough guides in
state of New Hampshire
[Music]
ever and with that I'll conclude my
testimony thank you much if nobody
objects I'm going to ask one question
first uh you mentioned that there's no
skin in the game would it be something
that fish and game should consider in
charging for the guides
license in my humble opinion yes um and
and so if I if I might be allowed to
expand a little bit it's your floor uh
so initially when I hope I'm not going
to step over to you're doing fine um
initially when this was started we were
doing tests every every
quarter uh so you had the opportunity to
take the test every quarter I'm not sure
so everything I tell you is about the is
about the oral board I I have no
involvement at all in the written
portion of this okay when they come to
when they come to the or board they
passed the written so it was every
quarter and what what happened was um
because there was no cost people just
showed up and and as a matter of fact I
believe I'm fairly accurate 25%
25% of the people don't show up for the
test because they have no skin in the
game so we show up myself at least one
Co maybe two cosos and they don't show
up for their exams so that's an
issue I'll lost my train sorry it's fine
any further questions uh we'll go with
rep con
first thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my uh
question uh can you walk me through that
the you know the step one to the last
step what is the process of getting this
license okay so
um so they I may miss some administ
strative things if I do I'm sort of the
colonel will correct me so you apply for
the license um you're given a test date
the next available test date uh at this
point it's the initial test it's twice a
year um it's available so you'd apply
for the license send in your money you
given a test date and and you take the
written if you pass the written so I
believe the written in this it I'll give
you the next cycle so if you you applied
today you'd be given a written date
February the end of February pass that
written test with minimum score of 70
you'd go on to be scheduled for a oral
board on a Monday in march sometimes
goes into April but usually finishes in
March um so once you once you the oral
board is comprised now of two sections
it used to be three
sections the the first section is
navigation it could be Land Navigation
it could be water navigation all this is
on I'm not giving away any super secrets
here um all this is on the website uh
it's it's some sort of navigation the
second section is we used to call a lost
person scenario it's actually more
accurately I think an emergency scenario
um
so something bad happens somebody could
get lost somebody could get hurt
somebody could get uh a whole number of
litany of things could happen and there
are responses that are expected based
on the information that is in that list
of study
guides can I have a followup Mr chairman
followup so all these things
happens until the somebody gets the
license the policy and the procedure
everything is implemented by the
commission right it's not just the
executive uh director the commission is
watching everything that happens with
the license in process I believe that
it's all in rule that I yes I believe
that it's all in rule so it's so it's
overseen thank
you any further questions representative
Smith please thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question is it
safe to say that there's written
findings uh during the oral board you
bet follow up follow up I didn't I
didn't mean to be there is absolutely
that I didn't mean to be no that's okay
is there any reason why a a written
result is not given to the applicant as
to why they fail yes uh so we originally
did so if you for instance you
failed aiming your
compass uh and I we originally would
immediately correct and I when I say
originally I believe it's 10 to 12 years
ago this started I can't give you an
accurate date I probably should be able
to do but I again um and what happens is
as soon as we give you the answer and
that was a that was
now uh that answer is communicated to
every single applicant forever more so
the test becomes now that should that
was a simple one but if I gave if I uh
for instance we have a we have right
now we had a test and we don't use it
anymore so I can give it away we we had
a test that was that was a person
wandered away from a fishing Expedition
um up in my neck of the woods ring
and that person walked away and I
actually had an applicant come to me
when we're as we're doing the test and
said oh no no no he's supposed to go
looking for wood right now so obviously
that had been communicated throughout
now there are guide schools um and and
those can be you know sometimes they get
involved in some of those trying to help
people pass well they always help people
pass but sometimes they can get involved
in those things but it they just over
time that gets around you know somebody
that pass a test you ask them what tests
they had so we're constantly have to an
evolve if we actually if if fishing game
was forced to actually do tests give
away the answers every two weeks and
then retest every two weeks there would
be multiple people involved in rewriting
tests
constantly to be able to provide that to
be able provide Integrity down the
road any further questions
representative Darby please thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um because there's different um types of
guides um can you talk about who makes
up the questions for the different uh
you know for the different
categories
um if you don't know it's okay to say
you don't know and we can pass that on
okay it's how much I can give
away um
the to be brutally honest the answers
are completely reflective of the
incident so uh but it wouldn't make any
difference the only difference between a
hunting and a fishing guide that came in
would be the the evolution that they
would be given so for instance if as a
fishing guide um I could end up with a
person that had a problem in a boat
while we were fishing where a hunting
guide would come in and maybe they they
had a problem with a person in a stand
that was hunting but the reaction to
those and the followup from the guide
is is should be appropriate to the
incident but
it's cut and dried it's not I will give
you an example we had a person that that
was asked to do navigation
and this is a test that we've had to
retire because it's been
learned uh but he actually said well I
would it happened to be in the early
morning said I would navigate by the
stars and the co and I looked at at each
other and went awesome we never thought
of that that's perfect wind yourself up
as long as you know how to navigate wisc
constellations that's a perfect answer
so that's an answer that we wasn't on
the paper but certainly we had to accept
so does that
help as far as the questions um they're
developed by in different ways um one of
the uh unfortunately recently deceased
lieutenants actually came up with the
one of the most recent tests follow up
thank you I guess I didn't understand so
you know don't test somebody that's
going off the Sea Coast uh ask different
questions than somebody that's you know
um trolling in Lake Waki no so that's
one of the other one of the other
difficulties for guides coming in is
that they we have guides that come to us
say well I'm just going to run I'm just
going to be a fly fishing guide and I'm
never going to use a boat well the
unfortunate part is we don't have that
that category doesn't exist in the state
of New Hampshire you are a fishing guide
period that is
east to west north to
south I will say it doesn't include you
don't have to have a license to be on
salt water that helps Vice chair goalie
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my
question being from the fire service and
familiar with the oral interviews and
things I I I think it's always important
that when you go to an
interview someone who has a background
in fire service or whatever you're
talking about is important to be part of
that process don't don't you wouldn't
you say that saying no guide should be
part of this process would do a
disservice to this exam versus being
involved in knowing what's going on and
what it
entails I couldn't agree more and coming
from the same background I've never I
never looked on the other side of taking
a test in the fire service and looked
across the table and found somebody that
never fought fire so I I absolutely
agree and that and that was why we
initially became involved was
Advocate almost exactly the opposite of
what would be portrayed here to advocate
for
guides thank you representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so um in listening to
some of your examples am I correct in
thinking that the oral exam is kind of a
practicum exam absolutely followup
please followup so um in a practicum you
you can either do it or not do it you
can you know whether you can do it or
you know whoops I not able to do this so
even without um you know feedback from
the uh from how you did on the test are
in your opinion are the the kinds of
things you're asking in the oral exam
kind of obvious to the person taking it
that they're able or not able to do um
what's being asked in the oral exam
because that seemed to be her problem
I'll give you two examples one so as far
as the navigation it's a it's a fairly
cut and dried thing some people walk
away and have no idea what they did
wrong on the other hand at this last
fall examination we had an individual
that went away from the navigation
portion came back and shook his head
like this and said I know exactly what I
did wrong um on the other
hand we have folks that when responding
to an emergency and they have a
uh issue that comes up that
that
um again I'm struggling not giving no a
test um that may come up that that
requires whether it be medical or it be
technical knowledge they may not know
that they uh for instance failed because
they didn't take care of the boat or
they didn't take care of the person so
does that does that help I mean they're
not
thank
you representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my
question following up on representative
Harvey a little bit so we heard earlier
that it's a one question oral exam and
that doesn't sound like what you're
saying you're saying it's a structured
test similar to doing a structured
interview you have three people on the
board all listening to the same question
independently um grading that question
and at the end cating their scores is
that correct that is correct okay thank
you and follow follow
up this is a different question we also
heard this morning uh earlier in
testimony that it seems like there are
those that believe that there have been
instances where a guide on this board
might have voted a certain way to keep
someone out of a job have you ever
experienced
that not personally I'm obviously that
have
not obvious be the guy since Co um uh
with I think one exception one day I
couldn't make it uh I have not and and
again I can't reiterate enough there
aren't enough guides this isn't a
limitation there this is if I could get
right now I have three people that call
me at the end of every testing to say
did you pass somebody that we can
hire it is that dire a need to get
people into the field to be able to
perform this
function thank you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today the chair
recognizes Jay
penson person Jody person sorry
good
afternoon I guess I want to speak in
support of this
bill and I I think I'd like to just
start out quickly as quick as I can
introducing myself
and uh my name is Jody person I'm
57 uh I've been a Avid uh bass I've been
bass fishing for over 30 years
professionally non-professionally
um I went and decided that I would like
to
uh become a guide I got to this point in
my life where I wanted
to I thought it would be a good idea um
to be a GU and take people out and share
my 40 Years of knowledge um anyways I'll
I'll explain I I started with doing the
paper test I signed up and got and did
the paper test um there was problems
with the paper test I failed the first
time the second time um there was
problems with the paper test but um I'm
sorry what was your Kevin Jord Kevin
Jordan here he actually took the reign
of the problems that there was with the
paper test and he corrected them because
there was a lot of questions on there
that had absolutely nothing to do with
fishing so I would congratulate on on
him getting a hold of that and getting
the paper test in line so I finally
passed the paper test and I went for the
oral
exam and I failed the map en
Compass uh bad I was not ready for that
I went in and I can admit that I was
definitely not ready for that I failed
for that so I went
and studied and to uh took a course
somewhere and everything you know and
and just went through and I learned a
lot and
um then uh I went in for my second time
theor exam and um I passed the map en
Compass I believe it's I've been this
process has been five years now going on
six years so I might be a little fuzzy
on how things happened but I'm giving
you the truth as as far as I can
remember
it um the second oral exam I failed um I
made it through map Encompass I believe
but then I failed on the oral part of it
and um of course you got to wait when
you when you fail twice you got to wait
a year so here I am waiting a year so
anyways I come back I had to they make
it startop from the beginning again so I
had to do the paper test I passed the
paper
test I got to the
oral my my thing was on the oral oral
pot when they kept failing you they
wouldn't tell you why you failed we've
already heard that spoke today I don't
want to repeat on that but it was it it
just seemed like every every time I
would ask the people that were there
there'd be conservation officer there
and and uh gu Association rep there and
I would ask the officer well why did I
fail and he would go like they usually
go like this and they paint they point
to the guide
Association um representative and then
that representative wouldn't wouldn't
tell you you know what you did wrong and
I was like well how am I going to learn
how am I going to learn to to do this
and then I'm off and I got to wait
another year and start again but
um uh so anyways that's that's that's my
story of where I've been with that and
um I want I guess I'll just jump to why
I bu why I'm a a supporter of house
build
1228 is I really think that it needs a
we need a committee that needs to be a
committee to get some kind of more
structure to this because it really is
such a broad thing for one person to try
to run this whole thing when you have if
you can have a committee you're going to
have uh more than one per one mind
working on this
um because the way it's set up right now
it's just I I feel it's not a fair
um it's not a fair playing field to to
get in
here um I think the committee would be
able to
address um like you
heard uh from someone earlier that this
this license is so broad the the fishing
license the guide fishing license is
Broad from border to border Rivers
camping going out in boats I can take
people clamming I mean it's it's it's
just it's it's all over the place and it
you know for myself I'm just like uh I
want to do freshwater bass fishing out
of a boat you know and I think if
there's a committee I think the
committee could actually break things in
like DMV does you don't you don't go in
and get a license for driving a car and
you can hop in a semi or this this
weight or this that you know I I think
it it needs to be structured out more
with that you know a committee would
really be good because they would be
able to say you know let's make a class
one and
two uh open water fishing license you
know it's it's it's not I don't think
it's a lot of work I just think uh you
know that's that's why we need a
committee and
um as far as the god Association is
being involved in this right now I'm I'm
not a lawyer or a judge but I believe
it's 100% illegal to have a private
entity joining with a department of New
Hampshire joining those two entities pie
together and having this private entity
making the decision whether I can get a
license or not when they're uh when
they're hired
guides they're guides for hire I mean
it's it's a 100% conflict of interest I
mean I I'm not a lawyer and I'm not a
judge but I have friends that are
lawyers and a I know a retired judge and
I've talked and it's like I mean it's
just it's crazy it's just just a little
bit out of control and I don't
understand
why
you know you you you think about this
guide
Association uh there it's it's almost
like putting them above the fish and
game offices that are
trained they're the ones when the phone
call gets made to go out and find that
person and save a life and do everything
why why are we jumping over the paper
test is given
by uh fishing game conservation offices
only the god Association is not involved
with that why I think that it just would
be fair
if the the oral is given too why do we
need a guide Association involved with
that which is a 100% conflict of
interest when you have the offices that
the ones that are actually trained in
it they're the ones that thank you Mr
person you're gone over your time and we
getting close to the uh well we've gone
over time for this hearing but uh if
you've got anything anything new that
you haven't covered already please state
it now and otherwise uh I thank you for
your testimony are there any questions I
think about that's about all I would
like to say at this time I I'll let uh
you go to questions then and and
representative Brown you're recognizes
ask questions thank you Mr chair thank
you for your
testimony are you willing would you be
willing to accept from the board when
they say you failed the oral test that
you you didn't pass this section as
opposed to as a previous testifier said
not giving you the question but you fail
in this section do they tell you that
and would that be your
preference um don't know if I understand
you mean like if they so you didn't pass
navigation but you don't have to know
the exact question or the
answer no I I think that should be given
you know um as far as that map ENC
Compass stuff
um they said they they weren't supposed
to tell me
and you know because you've heard the
reasons why but it's like I guess they
do that the oral is two separate the
oral the compass M Compass is one part
of the oral and the second is the
scenario the scenario is where it really
gets you know I don't have a problem
with the paper test the compass Ming
compass and stuff but when the scenario
gets going the scenario starts and I
know all a sudden it just starts taking
a life of its own and it goes and goes
depending on how if you rescue one
person I mean if if you're going to go
rescue one person there's a scene
there's probably three two or three
different ways you could go about it and
you're going to come out with the same
income I mean the same outcome you're
going to save the person's life it's
just it's it's very hard to go through
that oral scenario and say what they
want to hear I mean this
the three different ways to rescue
someone thank
you uh representative
paig thank you um so a previous speaker
said that there's a lot of structure to
the test there's a scoring rubric and
the various uh examiners collate their
scores at the end of this process when
you at the end of this process having
having not received a pass received a
fail yeah you just see you failed or do
you get some version of your scores for
the different sections on the oral
correct I get absolutely okay goose egg
thank you I get I get just stared at
and it's just it's you know it shouldn't
be like that I I have I have 100%
respect for these conservation officers
and everybody involved but yeah I
believe it may seem like a big thing
doing a committee to but
do we have any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you sir we've got more people to get
through uh chair recognizes Kyle Baker
you've asked for three
minutes representing the New Hampshire
Wildlife
Federation all right uh good afternoon
Mr chair uh members of the committee
thank you for your time my name is Kyle
Baker I'm with the Wrath young and
pellia Law Firm here in conquered and I
represent the New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation New Hampshire Wildlife
Federation is a uh Association that
represents approximately 50 different
fishing game shooting clubs um as well
as um an Affiliated membership of about
55,000 Sportsmen and women from around
the state um and we're here to oppose
this piece of legislation um mainly over
the concerns of uh the role of the guide
um in sporting whether you're Hunting
Fishing um or just just exploring
outdoor the outdoor spaces um is so
incredibly important and we think that
um the way the system works now um is
has worked and it continues to work to
provide the safest safest experience uh
for sportsmen and women across the state
um the rigorous education requirements
um the testing process um as you heard
um the guides that are involved in this
testing process um with the with the
conservation officers it's done on a
voluntary basis um there are not many
guides out there making a full-time
living uh working as a guide um most of
these folks are tied into their
communities whether they're Avid
fishermen Aid Anglers um Avid um
Hunters um they're very you know an
integral part um of outdoor recreation
and we think that this bill um could put
some of that at risk um we believe that
having the guides uh play a role um in
the testing um is incredibly important
to ensuring the safety for sportsmen um
when you you know to you know we've
talked about different licenses you've
heard testimony about different
licensing across the state um the you
know you're going to a doctor for a
procedure you want to see the doctor
that's done the procedure you need the
most times um when you are looking to
hire a plumber for something in your
house you want the best you want someone
who has the most experience in doing it
and we think that the Rings true uh for
guides um hunting and fishing guides as
well um hunting and fishing in New
Hampshire is also a source of Tourism uh
recently um the out the Outdoor
Recreation Department inside Bea listed
hunting and fishing as one of the
leading sources of Tourism dollars in
New Hampshire um it's incredibly
important that well-trained guides are
available to meet uh non-residents when
they come here looking to take advantage
of the unique um and vast outdoor
recreation opportunities we have um you
can be hunting in the North country and
fishing off the coast of the ocean all
within a couple of hours if you're lucky
enough to do it so we think that the the
the current process works um it's not
here to say it's perfect um by any means
and there's obviously uh always open to
conversations on how we can make the
process more efficient um as long as
we're ensuring that safety um is key um
these are folks that are putting you
know folks that are coming putting up
hard-earned dollars to get to get a
service um and we need to make sure that
they're getting what they're what
they're paying for so uh with that I
want to be respectful of your time and
happy to answer any questions that you
might have does anybody have any
questions seeing none thank
you uh chair now recognizes Richard
Burnham representing
himself asked for 5 to 10 minutes if you
can keep that on the Lower Side that'd
be great because we're running
behind thank you everyone my name is
Richard Burnham from Wolf bro New
Hampshire also very similar situation
where I've tried going through the
guides test through uh two or three
times within the course of several years
in which I've passed the written exam
and then gotten to the oral board and
gone through a few of the sequences But
ultimately failed and I come to hear to
you guys today in order to address the
fact of the whole conflict of interest
and one thing that gets me is for the
State of New Hampshire especially New
Hampshire fishing game for the hunter
education course and the Trapper
education course
that is strictly run by the New
Hampshire fishing game officers now for
the guides test we have the guides and
the New Hampshire fishing game officers
as part of that board and normally
there's only two instead of three at
least that's what I've experienced
usually one guide and one fishing game
officer and now the biggest thing with
me that I bring up is the whole
accountability aspect of it all and with
a guide being on the
board he may be qualified and have the
information necessary in order to pass
or fail an individual like he has that
background information but again what
stops that person from maybe leaking
that information to others what I've
noticed within the past of several years
if you look at the New Hampshire fishing
game guides list is there's actually a
lot of very like family members that are
all guides and it kind of interests me
on how they are able to pass so easy
easily versus others maybe not have that
same
experience the other thing I want to
bring up is also I have no problem with
a test I think the information what
we're tested on is totally fine it's
accurate that's what we should be
trained to do and
whatnot but how it's administrated is
one big problem there and as an educator
in New Hampshire one of the big things I
teach my students and just always go by
is to have a growth mindset and a growth
mindset is where you can learn from your
mistakes and in this case we don't have
that opportunity we don't know why we
failed and that is a big problem because
I can go back and back to the study
materials and still don't know why I
failed and if by providing some sort of
written report then I can understand all
right why I failed and improv myself
better for the next
time and is also having that committee
will help with that process of creating
these exams making sure everything's
fair and to go from
there thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you the chair now
recognizes Glenn
Burnham all right my name is Glenn
Burnham residents of wolf Bor I run a
construction out outfit um one of the
questions related David P about the cost
of this can you make sure you move into
the mic sure thank you that's just there
are people watching online as well and
pick your voice up better thank you sir
um the cpri cost we have to pay for
routinely so that is a cost as well um
as far as the transparency of this I
find that um you know it should be you
know if if you're answering a question
there should be an answer for it you
know and how do we know on these
scenarios on this oral exam that there's
not more scenarios being said to one
candidate to another I mean if they
failed on the first scenario then that
should be brought up and why did you
fail um you know I think it's a business
they can say what they want about oh
it's not a business I don't make a
living out of it it is a business and
one of the ladies over here said that
her husband hired a guide my question to
her is did you ask for proof of
insurance that should be like the very
first thing before you even step on the
boat you don't even know if you're safe
so regardless of this course if this guy
has no insurance you have
no you know nothing to claim on so I I
think there's a lot of loopholes in this
thing
I think um I think the state has to step
up and control it I don't like seeing a
third party I I just I just think
there's there's play for bad error
here um also um on another note I was
going to mention on he mentioned there
was 150 to 200 guides in the state well
how many of those guides took the test
and how many of those guides were
grandfathered in
that's a question I'd like to ask David
P you know so you talk about going out
with these guides you don't even know if
they even took the exam they've been
grandfathered
in so and you talk about well you know
it's so scary they need to have all this
um
accreditation in my book I run a
business I do bids for the Navy Yard I
do bids for the biggest chips and
wallboard plant in the
State I run a
risk it's a business that's exactly what
it is if I had to make a a bid against
another construction guy and I knew that
he had something up over me well that's
not fair that's like a pain company
owning their own pain manufacturer you
know apples for
apples um so when you say yeah all these
guides um are all qualified they're not
all qualified
there's a bunch of them out there that
are grandfathered
in so I don't know I just think you're
taking a situation here and I you know
we're making it bigger than what it
is thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony today thank you sir
and the last uh person I'll call is
Colonel Jordan from fishing
game thank you Mr chair I'm sorry that
we're running late I'm probably not
going to speed that up much cuz there I
appreciate that you might be able to
answer a lot of the open ends yes
there's a lot of uh information that's
been provided that is not at all
accurate so let me just tell you how
this process works so for many many
years uh fishing game provided a written
exam for a guide it was the same written
exam that was used better than a decade
and so the exam became as you can all
imagine very simple for everyone to pass
and we had a number of people passing
that that I questioned when I met them
in the woods hunting that these are qual
qualified people to take folks out and
remember I want to remind you what's
very most critical here we are taking
people out into the Wilderness that
don't have that experience they are
relying on the people who are taking
them out there to safely get them out
there and return them home without
injury that's a big deal that's a big
deal to me that's a big deal to my staff
and it's a big deal to the people that
are going out there so it's very key I
think that we improve that process so I
went to the guides Association I was the
guy who did that I went to the guides
Association CU those are the guys or
people not just guys those are the
people that are doing it um I look back
at Marty because she lectures me on on
coming into the 2000s and I'm trying
very hard to do that I'm a dinosaur so
the guides I we looked at other states
so we looked at the state of main who I
thought got it right the one thing the
state of main does is they manage their
guides a lot tighter than we do they
even get into what they charge and how
much they can charge I'm not looking to
do that as Free Enterprise in the state
of New Hampshire and and it's none of my
business but I did like their testing
procedure I thought that their testing
procedure was was a good measure of
skill sets and their testing procedure
is similar to ours so we kind of
mirrored that so what happens now when
you have someone who applies for a
guides license they have to have a CPR
certification or at least Wilderness
first aid because we want them to be
able to perform CPR and first aid on
injured uh people which by the way
happens a lot these people get injured a
lot they have diabetic shocks when
they're out there's all kinds of issues
that come up so to ask the guides to at
least be trained to that level uh is
appropriate they submit all that
paperwork we do a background check which
is another bill that you're going to
hear about later uh in an effort to
tighten up uh because we've had some
issues with that and I don't know if you
remember but we had a guide or an issue
come before this very committee a number
of years ago where a sex offender had
snuck under the wire became a guide and
was offending children in the Bob house
and we dealt with that yeah that came
here so So you you're going to hear that
again at a Senate bill that's coming
towards you for to try and prevent that
so they submit all that paperwork within
a window of time we put on the website
what that window of time is so it's very
clear to everyone that comes into my
office at law enforcement and the young
lady in their schedules a written exam
in which I take part in so I go down
when we score the exam and I take in
each and so we we change the exam I
asked the officers not the guides
Association the officers to create
questions that we could put in a bank I
had our it people create a bank of
questions for hunting a bank of
questions for fishing and we basically
go to this bank and say okay
representative goalie wants to take a
hunting exam so we'll pull out a hunting
exam which will have a number of
questions on it I can go back 5 seconds
later and ask for one for representative
Spain and it'll be very different it
will have hunting questions on it but
they will be different questions we're
very happy with that on occasion the
hunting exam will produce a fishing
question or the fishing exam will Pro
prod produce a hunting question as you
heard um and I forget um the gentleman's
name who who that occurred with Jody
Jody so the one thing jod didn't maybe
didn't understand or certainly it wasn't
communicated we don't score those
questions against their final score so
if I've got a gentleman in there taking
a fishing exam and there are hunting
questions in there that he missed we go
over it I tell him you missed the bass
question on your hunting exam but it
doesn't count towards his final score
because it's an incorrect question so
that is corrected he's right we do jump
on that but I think it's important to
understand that it doesn't count against
our score on that day if they in fact
pass that written exam we give them a
schedule for the next oral board exam
now the oral board exam is a very uh
involved test the officers get together
the guides Association comes in on their
own time volunteering their own time to
help us with this and we create an oral
board exam that we're going to give a
number of people we schedule four maybe
five a day at best because it takes some
time to go through this they're done in
two sections so normally there's and I
used to be a part of this for many years
it was done in three sections now it's
been changed to two uh but they do a
navigational piece be it on the water or
on land um because navigation of course
could is part of why we do search and
rescue is people are not good at that uh
so there's a navigational section and we
ask them to step out once we put them
through that exam and that exam is
scored and then they're brought back in
and they're told then that they failed
or passed that section if they pass that
section they move on to the next one
which would be the search and rescue
piece of it or the first aid piece of it
are the general guiding type scenarios
we may have some objects in the room we
want them to identify I like to see them
pick up a firearm make sure they don't
swing it around and point it at us that
they check to make sure it's empty I
mean we go through the whole just like
you did in Hunter Hunter Safety years
ago if they fail those sections we used
to tell them okay you failed map and
compass because you couldn't Orient your
map in your compass and this is how you
Orient your map in a compass the problem
with that was now we're just training to
the test everybody that came in we had
people coming in answering questions
before we could completely ask them
that's how educated they had become to
this one thing that hasn't been
mentioned at all today is New Hampshire
has a very good guide school that trains
these individuals to get through this
exam that's what they do it's not cheap
it's it's an expensive School I've never
been there but I know the instructor
I've talked to on numerous occasions the
man who manages it and we provide that
information to these people when they
fail so we'll say to someone when you
fail the navigation when you come back
in you need to strengthen your skills in
navigation I'm not going to tell them
you need to understand how to go from
point A to point B that's on them to
understand that I expect adults to take
that responsibility on their own I was
not told in the oral board uh when I
went to my first oral board for this job
and I knew nothing about the Sea Coast I
was not told I failed because I could
couldn't identify a clam I was told you
fail because you don't know anything
about the coast dummy go back and learn
the coast and you can com and I got
through the the exam I I think it's a
mistake to tell them exactly why they
failed I don't think it's a mistake to
say you failed
navigation here are some resources we'll
give you to Bone up on your navigation
we give them uh a gentleman who teaches
map and Compass teaches it to my staff
we give them the guide school resource
list to say that we don't provide them
with that information is incorrect we do
whether they take advantage of it or not
is another thing that's up to them we do
allow them to retest unlike the state of
Maine we don't charge them for that we
don't charge for any of the testing our
charge is the $100 fee for the
license that that money is returned to
them if they fail the exam that we don't
take that money until they buy the
license so they can take that exam 14
times they're not going to pay any any
additional money um what did happen in
the beginning because this test was a
huge step in the very beginning as you
can imagine inagine we had a high
failure rate uh a number of people
failed and so we began to offer them the
next round of oral boards to retake that
exam and what was happening is we had so
many failures in the beginning we were
not getting any new people I was pushing
new people off 6 to8 months because we
were still trying to get the people
through who couldn't pass it the first
three times and so quickly we figured
out we got to do something different
let's allow them to take it twice and
then let the then this way we'd be able
to keep our line moving forward the new
people who could pass could come in and
get their opportunity and the people who
fail could come back they are allowed to
come back within a month and take that
test again if they fail a second time
then we make them wait a year and that's
on our that's uh publicly shared we tell
them that at every step of the way so
that they understand if they fail that
test again that they they they have to
wait a year before they can retest and
that's the reason for that is we want to
move it forward I would like I truly
would like to have enough officers so I
could dedicate five of them to this
process alone unfortunately with all the
things that we got going on on a
day-to-day basis I just don't have the
staff for that we have two people doing
they keep talking about the
commission the commission has nothing to
do with this our Fishing Game Commission
does policy they manage the agency from
the 60,000 foot view if you will they
manage the direction of the agency the
legislative process they do not assign
staff to anything the director does that
or his designate does that so the the
guy committee or the committee that
makes this decision the oral board is
the oral board itself it's not a single
person it's the oral board who tests the
director I don't think the director's
ever been to a test he he we advise him
on where we're going and how many have
passed and and what stage we're in um so
it's it's a number of but it takes guys
have got to get together they've got to
line up their schedule so they commit a
full day with no calls for service they
can't respond to any call because
they're committed to this exam and so
then that exam exam is provided again
these they have a number of tests they
keep rotating these and to answer your
question which was a great questions who
comes up with the questions for this in
the oral board It's a combination of the
officers and the guides Association that
will create scenarios and questions that
are
provided um and and the other argument
that I I couldn't disagree with more is
the fact that the feeling or the belief
that the guides Association is a
conflict Dave pointed out David P
pointed out that the electrician board
has electricians on it the no Hampshire
bar has attorneys on it the medical
board is medical doctors nursing board
is Nurses I could go on all day it it
just makes sense to have people that do
this for a living decide whether others
are fit to do it or not uh if you file a
complaint on a defense attorney which
I've done it goes to a bunch a board of
attorneys to review and decide if the
attorney made a mistake or not it's it's
just the way things are done and it
makes good sense to do that we do not
have enough guys guides there's no
shortage of uh we don't have an there's
no there's no reason for a guide the GU
any member of the guide Association to
not want more people doing this cuz
there just isn't isn't enough guides to
go around the state we're getting more
and more calls every day for that so the
thought of of eliminating them and
having my officer sitting there silently
while a guide says well I don't want
another guide so I'm going to cut this
guy out is ludicrous that just doesn't
happen and it never would happen under
that scenario so it's not a decision
that falls solely to the guides
um I've managed not to follow a single
word of my outline so I would like to
make sure which is typical you can
submit that if you'd like to submit that
to the clerk I just want to make sure I
hit on all the points no that's great we
appreciate in the interest of time that
you don't read through everything no no
I wouldn't do that
um so I guess at this point I I would
ask you not to change it I think it I
personally think it is going in the
right direction I feel bad for people
that can't pass it but we can't tell
them what they need to do to pass I
can't teach the test I'd rather have
them skilled in the in what they're
going to do that's more important to
have them go back and study an area that
they're weak in to to improve in that
and pass the test so I I by no means we
insulting anyone and I don't I we're not
in the business of not making them
guides I just want to make sure uh that
when we turn them out they are they are
qualified and the last thing I want to
leave you with I've done this for 33
years a long time I know it's stupid but
I have we have never ever in the history
of my involvement at New Hampshire
fishing game ever conducted a search and
rescue mission involving a guided hunt
or a guided fishing trip that says
something I have been involved in two
fatalities in the state of Vermont that
doesn't regulate guides that involve
guided fishing trips to individuals who
drown so if you think for a minute it's
not important it is important it happens
in other states that don't regulate it
they have a hard time with it in Maine
and New Hampshire we don't because I
think I think it's because we regulate
it we make sure these people are
competent before we turn them loose to
bring people out and we want to make
sure that they bring them back I think
that's an important point Thank You
Colonel appreciate your testimony uh
before I open it up for questions for
everyone I've got an ask of you and I I
appreciate the balance between not
having enough guides in the state and
wanting to keep people interested in
applying yes but I would ask that your
department get us information what it
costs you to run the guide testing every
year since you're not charging anything
for it I think that might be a situation
where we've got to drain on the budget
that should not be there yeah I can do
um and I will now allow the uh Vice
chair to ask his question thank you Mr
chair thank you Colonel for taking my
question
uh looking at the
oral I'm sure it's probably something
similar to the fire service that I'm
familiar with where you're given a
scenario a real life scenario something
happening yes and in that scenario you
have a checklist of those critical
criteria Maybe five things you missed
one of those five things it isn't just
10 points off you fail that completely
because that's a critical criteria
absolutely that's exactly how it's go
down the list and there's somewh you
minus five points because yougot
something corre is that how I understand
this it is how it's done and I think
that's where the confusion comes in that
one question can fail you for instance a
your client has goes into diabetic shock
what would you do with that client and
if you do the wrong thing you could kill
that client and that's a critical
question um so yes that's exactly how
it's done is is there's a series of
steps that we're looking for and I will
say this it is very open-ended in that
it isn't a a there's not as you know
there's not in any emergency situation
there are things we would all like to
see done that doesn't mean there isn't
an idea out there we hadn't thought of
that would work and every now and then
they get thrown that curve and we accept
that that's not it doesn't have to be in
writing like we've got it as long as the
results are achieved and the client is
safe and you've done everything in your
power to ensure that um that is how we
do it that's exactly how we do it
representative Mooney thank you Mr chair
thank you for the question and all the
information do you publish previously
asked or retired questions and scenarios
for the applicants thank you we've never
published the test uh a test would be
exempt I believe from right to know I'd
have to look at that but I think test
and results of test are exempt from that
in effort to protect the the
um uh the the what's the word I'm
looking for the protesting to protect
the Integrity of the test so no we don't
we don't publicly publish that no we do
put out a lot of information on the
website regarding what areas you should
be knowledgeable in and where to find
resources to study for that follow up
just very quickly I understand not
publishing the test but previously
retired questions that w or sample
scenarios that you wouldn't ask on the
actual exam no we haven't done that
that's that's not a bad idea to do on
retired ones that we've done if we have
those Banks most professions that you
mentioned in your list do do that thank
you yep thank you that's a good question
and uh representative
Ford thank you Mr chairman thank you
Colonel for my question um always enjoy
your honesty um one of the former folks
who gave their testimony said they were
educator and I realized I too am an ed
educator and recognize that a lot of my
students learn in different ways and I'm
wondering if there are other ways in
which someone who may need a different
um examination um receive that and also
get scored in an equal manner as if they
were not getting accommodations if if
that makes sense and it does does
fishing game allow for accommodations
for written and oral examination when it
comes to the guides so that's a good
question too we've talked about that
that's part of the reason that I get
involved in the written exam and take
each individual out and go over it
question by question cuz that's a that's
a qu that's a test that's not going to
be like that again so you can do that so
when we have the opportunity to do that
we do it I don't know how you do it I'm
not sure how you could do it in an oral
board and keep it fair for everyone I we
struggle with that but yes we have we
have entertained that we have I don't
want to say we've numb tests that's what
I was going to say so I guess I'm going
to say it we have numbed a test down we
have created tests in the past that we
felt were too difficult too too high in
expectation and we've we've reduced that
down uh to address that but we but it's
limited what we can do follow up thank
you Mr chairman and then the second
question how many of your officers have
been or currently are guides that's a
good question I have had
uh I've had two or three that were
guides I believe most of us are not um
and and there's a reason reason for that
but I've had two or three that were I I
don't honestly think I would have the
patience for it and I and to be
perfectly honest with you I think some
of the things that I've heard about I've
seen pictures where guides have been
over and let a client lay across their
back to shoot I I don't think I could do
that so I none of that we've had but we
have had I think we've had three that I
can think of uh and two of those are now
retired so we have one right now that is
a
guide and uh representative Morton
oh but by the I will one other thing I
think is important I have made the all
of my officers every one of them take
the exam the written exam and they have
participated in the oil because if they
can't pass it you can't expect anyone
else to so thank you for that
representative Morton thank you Mr chair
and thank you C Jordan um for taking my
question my first thing is on average
about how many applicants do you get per
cycle I'm kind of got the impression
that there's basically two cycles a year
right is two now we've reduced It 2 two
because of the time involved we're doing
backgrounds on all of them we probably
do I'm going to say 30 to 50 each time
probably follow up
and can you give me a percentage of of
how many pass I knew you going to ask
that so it was it was pretty low in the
beginning quite honestly uh once the
guide school got going and people
started understanding this is the tough
test they we've improved that this last
round that we just finished I think it
was I looked at it was a 70% pass rate
we're passing I I'm I'm comfortable when
I tell you we're passing more than we
fail does everybody pass it no they
don't no they don't followup last thing
um one of the speakers spoke about
grandfathered um guides can you just
good point yep there were some Grand
he's absolutely correct um I didn't know
how to deal with that I didn't think it
was fair to take like we do anything
that we do you gr grandfather you you've
missed those people unfortunately
because you weren't strict enough back
then I couldn't agree with him more some
of those folks shouldn't be out there
that's the goal of this whole process is
to make sure that we don't do that again
we are slowly weeding out those
grandfathered guyses there aren't many
of them left most of the people that are
well a lot of the people that are on
right now have gone through the or I
went to a recent guide association
meeting legislative meeting they invited
me to attend and most of the people at
that table had gone through the process
and I will tell you this that that is
something that guides and I didn't bring
any ask any of those people to come in
here but they feel it's a badge of of
honor to have gone through it they feel
this is this has brought their field of
profession to a to a more higher
professional level and they're very
pleased with that those from those from
who have passed
certainly representative
AAR thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question Sergeant my
question is um so you're uh colonel
sorry Sergeant is fine long as you send
the check you can call me anything you'd
like um thank you um so you oversee the
New Hampshire guides Association and the
accountability of of what you have I
noticed you you have some metrics of
what the pass Ray is yes and so
concerning that there's so many people
here um with testimony that they
experienced people pointing at them do
you have
meetings with um the New Hampshire
guides Association on a regular basis to
go over um these things thank you we go
over we I've gone over it with the
guides who have participated in the oral
board I've not gone over it with the
association we've gone because um some
of those people are the test takers but
we've gone over it with the people who
the the the oral board is a constant I
think your question the oral board is
constantly uh evaluating what they're
doing and how they're doing it how to
improve it the test are always changing
so yes the answer to that would be yes
we don't do it with the entire
Association I'll tell you I've learned
that you have to be really this this
test is valuable to get out I've learned
that the hard way so we're very careful
that's why Mr P was answering or
testifying very carefully because we've
had issues with these questions in the
manner that we give it getting out and
we feel that defeats the whole purpose
so we guard it representative Harvey
ju just curious are there any um
requirements for reupping like you know
teachers need to be recertified every
three years is there anything like that
in no no so as long as your record is
that's a good question we nobody
testified to that as long as you you get
through it once and your record remains
clean from violations you just renew for
the feed of the license and and produce
your certifications for first aid and
CPR to make sure it's current and you're
back in you don't have to retake it
and representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Coral yes sir for all the great work you
do for all of us and you and you know
your department um every testimony and
every bill has a merit and lot of things
came out and I think that U there is
some room for improvement for this
testing and results and uh citizen
friendly uh guides that the process
citizen friendly process so is it
possible my question to you is is it
possible that the within the commission
the rule can be changed and it could be
more citizen friendly in future we don't
need another
RSA I would agree we don't need another
RSA um and I certainly would I certainly
would be willing to I mean we've had
some of those Dave and I have had some
of those discussions already about how
we might be able to improve it I think
there is a limit to how much you can
change you know some of it falls to
people becoming educated when they come
in if they want to pass this thing but I
would be willing to go back to see if
there's any way maybe on you know coming
up with a way to provide the results in
a more understanding way if people are
struggling with that without providing
questions you know I I think we could
David I'm sorry but I think we could
improve that yes thank you any other
questions okay as a final leaving of
going to on be speaking for the
committee I'm going to request that you
provide us information on how much it
costs your department to run these test
here and I'm going to suggest that the
department uh and the guides testing
reach out to Frank edbl to find out
about potential accommodations for
people who learn differently okay and
have him maybe review and come up with
potentially solutions that don't dumb
down the answers but provide a different
methodology to the testing process okay
we can do that thank
you and with that uh if there's anybody
else who needs to add to this that
hasn't put in a pink sheet let me know
and otherwise we're going to close the
hearing
on
all right we are far behind and the
sponsor of 1417 has had an emergency so
what we're going to do is ask that uh I
recognize representative pair and she's
going to introduce it and we're going to
suspend and we're going to go on to the
next bill after that
um let's give me a a minute here to
everything taken care
of
all right I'm going to open 1417 and
recognize representative
peir thank you Mr chair uh yes 1417 is
uh relative to um wild trout
management and uh I hope everyone on the
committee has a has a copy of this uh
representative Reed has been has been
called away so I'm introducing
1417 at at this time
thank you and the chair will now uh
recess 1417 to a datetime and certain of
9:30 on February
6th 1417 is closed for
now and give us a few minutes because
the prime sponsor for the next bill is
coming up from
Finance
that's fine I think she was the only one
missing anyway so had to be the correct
one unless it was
Rosner but it doesn't
matter sorry
the position they sit in does not matter
to me in the least I have more important
things to worry
about okay okay being behind schedule
we're going to open up a 1530 and call
Representative Hull the prime sponsor of
the
bill
good afternoon members of fishing game
representative Hull um representing the
towns of Dunbarton hooks at Allenstown
in Epsom here to introduce house bill
530 or sorry 1530 relative to body
cameras for conservation
officers several years ago we put in the
statute the ability for various Law
Enforcement Officers to wear body
cameras this is done to protect both the
civilians as well as the officers
themselves
and it's done that way so that there's
real evidence that can be talked about
later in terms of what happened at an
incident um unfortunately conservation
officers in my eyes and the way the
statute is written in 105 are not
necessarily just a straight law
enforcement officer and because when you
give an itemized list if conservation
officers doesn't make the magic lists it
may not be clear whether they have
access to or should be required to wear
these cameras
um so I'm here in testifying in favor of
passing HB 1530 to allow officers to
wear these cameras and then once it
passes here it has a fiscal note to it
it's headed over to finance we will
figure out where in the budget we need
to get the finance to make this
happen
um part of this also goes in reference
to how the recordings are maintained and
who has access to them um people have
expressed potential concerns about the
privacy of of these recordings but in
any case where there's legal action
against a citizen obviously the defense
Council and the citizen themselves per
part first Article 15 should have access
to that information so that they can in
fact put together their
defense
um other than that at some level it's a
housekeeping measures just to make sure
we're including conservation officers in
our current statutes relative to body
count body
camera off for police
officers with that I'll close my
testimony unless there's direct
questions thank you I have one myself uh
before I open it up to the others I
would ask you uh there's a section that
asks about uh or says that they should
turn on their cameras when teaching or
participating in any capacity in a
hunter education class if I'm reading
that correctly uh is there a reason we
would be recording Hunter education
classes so so in all cases is right if a
law enforcement officer is being paid
and they are in front of the public we
would want them right to be accountable
if there's an accident I'm not saying
there's an accident that right two two
students get into an altercation right
and the the conservation officer will in
fact be the first responder to that
altercation right this gives plenty of
evidence so um whether the state chooses
to prosecute or not whether one of those
wants to do a civil action against the
other there is at least something to to
quantify in in
audiovisual right what happened so it's
they're doing a job for the state at
that point so it should be inclusive of
all of their job that is currently not
listed in in 105 so that would make
would would add to the list thank you
and I can confirm to the committee this
is an early bill it is going to finance
to try to figure out where the money
comes from for these um it is an early
bill um so it has a second committee to
go through and with that I will take
questions does anybody have any uh we'll
start with representative Harvey because
your hand was up really immediately I'm
sorry I it it isn't an order of
importance but thank you Mr chair um and
thank you for taking my question um I
sit on a budget Committee in my hometown
and we talk about body cameras a lot for
police officers and one of the issues
that has always brought up is the
storage and the um having the enough uh
space for the storage H how is that
addressed so so that would be part of
the financial and the contract right in
all likelihood the department would
would um hire or contract with an
outside agency who is responsible for
camera maintenance camera upkeep as well
as things like data storage um given the
world that we live in data storage is is
growing um enormously fast around around
the world as as more and more video is
created captured and stored so follow up
thank you so that would all be part of
what is discussed then in finance
correct so so if I can this is a policy
is this the right policy for fishing
game if this is the right policy for
fishing game this then moves over to
finance and we have to figure out where
in I believe it' be division one the
money's going to come from to do
this and we all already have contracts
with some camera providers for storage
and cameras with the state correct
correct and there is already a fund for
some of this the question is do they
have legal access today to that fund and
it's not real clear this bill addresses
that and that's the finance question any
other questions representative per you
still have a question go for it uh you
mentioned that um the officer camera
should be on when they're teaching
hunter safety courses um police tend to
hold public events and go to schools and
and um participate in other things that
are not what we might consider directly
part of their active duty right do they
have to record those I'm hesitant that
um this bill doesn't speak to that no
but it you
um uh referenced the the fact that um
this is similar to what police officers
do in uh so I'm just wondering if
these sort of ancillary things are
recorded in other services I I don't
believe they are that's why if you look
at what is currently
in end of
um section three starting right at 3A
right there's a list of things where
there's recording images in the current
105 this is page two starting at line 17
and down okay and the things that are
one two 2 three four are are all current
law five sorry uh it would be before B
and C C and D would be
new
and um Hunter education is not the same
as a law as like a classroom so Hunter
education is someone choosing to
participate with the department for the
purpose of learning and that it's
different than let's say a law
enforcement officer going into a school
to teach a a dare course
okay all right thank
you Vice chair
goalie thank you Mr
chair I need to follow up with that last
remark you made because I know in
Manchester we have the Dare program
where police officers train kids whether
it's boxing or it stuff like
that and I do not believe they wear
cameras for those events
why would
that differentiate between that and
hunter's
ed so I it was drafted in such a way
that it includes all of the duties where
the law enforcement officer and this say
conservation officer is performing their
job um that is currently not the
standards for
police relative to things like teaching
dare courses right they might come in
and teach they might come in and teach
uh some sort of generalized safety
course relative to walking to your car
late at night to 11th and 12th
graders I don't believe those are
currently covered under
law
followup would you be amendable to
changing it so that it's the same
situations as police officers currently
where it's we interaction with someone
that is recorded not on all of their
duties depends how you Define
interaction with someone right this is
set up to just broadly capture their
their role as a conservation officer um
so if you do an interaction with
someone what happens if they are in the
field they see an animal animal's got an
arrow sticking out of its chest right
does that get recorded they're not
interacting with somebody but that's
actual tangible evidence that's going to
be needed later
on so conservation officers do in fact
do law enforcement under 207 I don't
remember the exact section um one of the
attorneys behind me can probably point
out where under the Conservation
Commission there is a rule they are also
allowed to do any law enforcement duties
um in the do the DMV
statutes but they also were in the field
and they're doing things like
interacting with what's with this dead
animal right how did it get to be there
and and and there's different duties
where it's not just interacting with
people so I would think it has to be
defined a little bit more
broadly thank
you any further
questions representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question representative um section three
which is the section where the
additional criteria has is being added
the the Clause line on um line 21 of
page two um says is talking about re
retaining recordings for a minimum of
three years when and you know it says
the the two cases we've talked about
here teaching and interacting with
Sportsmen so this is actually saying
that um every interaction with Sportsmen
have to has to be retained for three
years whereas in the standard case as
described in at line 18 they can be um
uh over uh re-recorded after between 30
days and 180 days so why would these
have to stick around for three years so
I believe that's current law um if
someone can pull up that section of
Statute right I don't believe that is a
change the way this is the way ol drafts
things right if that was in bold that
would be a change to current law I
believe that is our current law um D
interactions with Sportsmen including
but not limited to Hunters Trappers and
fishermen is bold and yes I understand
to 22 and so is the
teaching2 is is would be statute
correct if if drafted by o that's the
way I to
expect it doesn't say repeal and replace
it's it's a
modify if someone has a book otherwise
I'll quickly pull it
up Mr
chairman I can I can confirm that that
rep kofalt uh thank you Mr chairman yes
I can confirm that that um lines 18
through 22 are in current Statute in
Section 105
D2 thank
you but I think the question was why
does the criteria include now a new
criteria of interactions with Sportsmen
as being a reason you would keep it for
three years instead
of and that's new the criteria C and D
are both new criteria for holding at 3
years correct C and D are added to the
statute right and they would fall to
hold for three years not just 30 days or
until something happen and we could set
that up that if that was either the 30
or the 180 Day level right the the three
years was capture was was a broad term
but that was existing statute I wasn't
making changes to that I was just adding
certain cases where we should be
capturing data or capturing
interactions so did you want to follow
up um
I I I understand the intent the intent
is to make sure that these um
interactions um with Sportsmen and in
training facilities are uh recorded but
it appears to me um that where it was
put in uh where where lisr um sorry OLS
captured this is stating that you're
going to require this to be stored for
three years in all cases okay
I agree that's the way I read it to
representative Darby and and it probably
should have been in the in the 180 days
area or what have you the standard
unless something happened in the class
or in the
interaction that made it
evidentiary any other questions
yeah representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman
so on D on interactions with Sportsman
do do you think that might
include and speaking from personal
experience where fishing game
conservation officer may go on a field
trip as a as a scientific
expert uh can you better describe what
this situation would be I'm not aware
that fishing game officers go on field
trips as scientific experts so yes they
do and and having uh worked at Dees for
years we used to we used to do uh field
trips we used to take the waste
management Council out to the to the
coast and explain programs and often
fishing game would come along as an
expert on on Coastal issues or whatever
and similar to what we did this summer
with the boat so you have people there
as let's call them uh uh what's the word
scientific experts that's not the right
word but uh okay and what that that is
it could be considered to be an
interaction under d i I would I would
put that under an interaction okay um
right because potentially any of those
members in that group could be Sportsmen
right if they're doing something at the
ring y okay thank
you uh representative
goalie thank you Mr chair I got to go
back to this is I'm not sure why
there's two stand
one for conservation officers and one
for regular law enforcement on line 26
on page
one that if the firearm is used for uh
the dispatch of an animal for law
enforcement it doesn't need to be
preserved but if it does for by a
conservation officer it is preserved I
want to know why there's that double
standard that versus you have a police
officer and a conservation officer on
the same scene with an animal that's hit
by a car if one of them dispatches the
animal the recording does doesn't need
to be saved but if the other one does it
has to be recorded and
captured
so it's an assumption on my part it's
probably would be born out if we asked
for data that conservation officers um
especially in the field interact with
more animal carcasses than they do right
let's say they found they find an animal
um that's been hit by an arrow and it's
flopping around in and they're to put it
down right police officers especially
state troopers are going to see the
animals hit by cars right that and they
may be charged with putting them down
but in this case fishing game officers
are going to be be pursuing something
that might be a crime more than a car
impact to an
animal their jobs descriptions are
different follow
up so I guess my question goes
to should all of these incidents be
recorded or just those in where a crime
may be involved
or and I just don't see the double
standard where two people at the scene
depending on who dispatches the animal
whether it's saved or isn't saved it's a
good point and the question is is in
putting down that animal something
that's tangible evidence necessary
for hypothetically right if we're going
to use a HP pathetical situation right
we have a um a motor vehicle operator
Under the Influence hits a deer right
causes some other accident along the way
so maybe that needs to be preserved the
dispatching of that animal and that we
need to update the statutes there
because that might be valuable
information in the prosecution or
potential prosecution for a driving
Under the
Influence representative Harvey uh thank
you Mr Mr chair and thank you for taking
my question um so the longer we talk
about this the more and more confused
I'm getting because um um there's so
many
interactions so-called with with
Sportsmen that I don't think has to be
recorded for
instance um they've often taken our
committee on field trips that that
doesn't need to be recorded in fact I
wouldn't want me being recorded there so
I'm just wondering if you would be
amenable to you know maybe an interim
study or something because I I'm just
sitting here listening to this and I'm
getting more and more
confused so I broadly speaking if the
bill was filed for the inim study right
we could have done this study without a
bill right we could we as legislators we
could um look at the topic ourselves
bill was filed to make changes to the
statutes for the purpose of making sure
that interactions with within this
department um were captured and that
this department would have access to the
funds that are available for other
departments that they don't have
today other questions representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you again
for taking my question um I am I am
concerned actually as I read the rest of
the statute on 105 D2 which is the use
of body warn cameras which is what um
section three amends
for example um subsection 7e says that
interactions with a person s seeking to
report a crime anonymously should not be
recorded it also says that um on uh
police officers or sorry law enforcement
officers on the grounds of a public
private or parial school should not be
recorded these seem to contradict
directly with CD um that as
introduced okay um let me
you said section seven I'm pulling it up
so I can I can take a look at it 105 d27
E and F as
examples I did not ask OSS to make
changes to the rest of the statute right
it was the language change was relative
to the H Hunter education classes and
then kind of w interacting with Hunters
Trappers and fishermen right in the
field and maybe we need to make it clear
that it's in the
field
right um I didn't I wasn't part of the
group that wrote
105d that this is OS as we requested of
os put into statute right recording
under the following
circumstances question the chair
question of the chair go
ahead thank you Mr chair
I'm getting really confused in this
subject matter it's
almost criminal justice Public Safety
type of material not fishing game
committee material that we're dealing
with and unfortunately if this goes to a
second committee it's going to finance
and not criminal justice for a proper
vetting because there's a lot in this
statute I think that we're covering that
really needs to be looked at in order to
go forward with something of this nature
and I'm just looking for guidance or
ordinarily I would have argued that
criminal justice probably was the right
committee I think given workloads of
various committees um and it being
relative to fish and game conservation
officers that probably got pushed over
here but again I don't think anybody in
our room in this room here had any part
of that
decision slightly not and
um I
uh don't doubt that we should probably
uh have potentially criminal justice
take a look at things as well however
it's obvious that there's several areas
that need Amendment amending already as
it stands because they seem to be in the
keep it for three years rather than the
standard area Etc so um I'll have to
consult with the chair of Criminal
Justice and the speaker and see what uh
what Avenues are open for that type of
thing um for today I think that it helps
us flesh out other issues that can be
brought forward by an amendment for the
sponsor before it hits another committee
if we continue listening to some other
testimony that we're going to hear from
some other people here so I won't cut
the hearing short at this point but um
we'll keep that in
mind representative Harvey so so this is
a question of the chair as well because
I don't know the time do because this is
an early Bill do we have time to do all
of what you're suggesting I mean I I
that's why I'll be talking to the
speaker okay okay thank you
representative
peir thank you Mr chair I think this may
be more question for you but whatever um
we need to also be aware of adding extra
cost in editing these things you know
this 20 minutes gets saved here and that
hour and a half gets saved there um we
don't want to get too bogged down in the
in the details
of okay I'm guessing um we don't want to
get too bogged down in the details of
what these recordings are and and so
forth again all of that can be done via
the thank you for the question all that
can be done via the contract with the
Outside Agency who would oversee the
cameras and the storage um if you start
getting into parsing this has to be kept
for 30 days and this has to be kept for
180 days and this has to be kept for 3
years I get you the the default should
be we keep it for the 30 or 180 or
whatever the the default is and then
only if there's an ex
uh uh if there's an extenuating
circumstance that affects something
because it needs to be kept evidentiary
evidentiary you can tell it's late in
the day um that triggers the longer then
we would trigger the longer period of
retention okay um so if there are any
other questions we'll move on with more
and if not then thank you for your
testimony today um I would welcome you
to uh take the ideas back for an
amendment and uh we'll make sure we get
you some notes from the secret uh the
clerk here as well so that you can know
what was what was important okay thank
you thank you um I am now going to
recognize Steph andrees and Paul
[Music]
helverson maram
County Attorney's
Office
good afternoon my name is Stephen andw
I'm an assistant County Attorney at the
Marat county attorney's office with me
is attorney Halverson he's the maram
County Attorney both of us have been
prosecutors for over 20 years at this
point um when you look at 105 D2 the
body warant camera statute it's actually
a very comprehensive statute that a
number of stakeholders came together
when they P it was involved there were
defense attorneys um there were
representatives from the Department of
Safety police officers police Chiefs and
they came up with a fairly comprehensive
bill that really can be broken down into
two parts the first part of 105 D2
addresses the creation of bodyw warn
cameras in the field the second part of
105 D2 really addresses the handling of
bodyw warn cameras after those
recordings have been made uh that second
part the handling section had I think
can be further broken down into
essentially four sections the first
being um copying or uh Distributing the
bodyw warn cameras the second being
accessing those bodyw warn camera
recordings the the third subsection
being storage of the body warn camera
recordings and the fourth being the
actual retention of the body warn camera
recordings as the sponsor indicated it's
really a policy whether or not you want
fishing game officer
to be wearing body warn cameras I think
under the current statute there's
nothing that would prevent fishing game
from equipping its conservation officers
with body warn cameras this bill would
make it mandatory that fishing game
officers have body warn cameras and it's
worth noting that that would make
fishing game the only agency in the
state of New Hampshire that's mandated
to use bodyw warn cameras uh right now
the state police are using body warn
cameras but there's no mandate that they
use them a number of local police
departments use them but there's no
mandates that any of those agencies use
body warn
cameras
because really it's a policy of whether
or not fishing game should be using body
warn cameras I I would suggest that
instead of looking at 105 D2 that
comprehensive statute instead of
amending that it might make more sense
to put something in
20625 where it actually talks about the
power of conservation officers or
fishing game officers and I think
frankly to the extent you wanted a
policy that fishing game used body
wearing cameras you could put a one-
sentence Statute in there that says
fishing game is authorized to equip its
conservation officers with bodyw warn
cameras um in compliance with 105
D2 what concerns me about this bill is
the reference to Discovery in um
sentences 14-
16 again when we talk about body warn
camera videos it's without getting into
a lot of detail it's worth realizing
that there's more on those videos than
just police officers and defendants
there's Witnesses there's
victims um if the police come to my
house and say hey can we talk to you
about you know your neighbor doing
something I may ask them into my house
and now there's a recording of the
inside of my house and me speaking to
the police one of the things that the
police often do whenever they talk to
anyone is they get that person's full
name they get their data birth they get
their address all that's captured on the
body warn camera uh when you think about
victims of domestic violence when the
police arrive you may see people with
bruises bleeding um and essentially we
all recognize that the police generally
aren't interacting with people on the
best day of their life that this is
often the worst time that this person's
having you also have to bear in mind
police are interacting with people that
are in Mental Health crisis that are on
on drug drugs or alcohol having those
types of crisises and again if I could
stop you just for a second yes we're
drifting a lot into what police are
doing and not so much into what the
fishing game officers are doing on it
fishing game is limited in its
interactions on police details to just
the DMV area under 207 how so the rest
of that is what they might encounter in
the field correct they're not doing
mental health checks if we could just
rein this in a little especially since
we're running behind and the reason I
bring all that up is because this bill
amends discovery not just for fish and
game but for all law enforcement in the
state of New Hampshire that are using
body Waring cameras so this would allow
all law enforcement in the state of New
Hampshire using body warn cameras to
duplicate that recording and provide it
to the defendant with no privacy
protections whatsoever it goes well well
beyond fishing game and that's my
concern is that you're amending 105 D2 a
bill that covers all law enforcement in
this one bill there are currently bills
before the Senate and the house there's
a Senate Bill 362 and a house bill 1021
that specifically deal with discovery of
body warn cameras that are going through
the Senate Judiciary and house criminal
justice committee with reference to the
the teaching and interacting sections of
this
um this proposal
those sections are amendments to the
retention statute so again when I talked
about 105 D2 and I said the first part
talks about the creation of body warn
cameras to the extent you want Hunter
education classes or interactions with
Sportsman recorded that shouldn't be in
the retention section that should be in
the creation section because right now
under 105
D2 um police are
prohibited from indiscriminately
recording entire duties or patrols the
police are only able to record on the
arrival on arrival on scene for a call
for service or when engaged in law
enforcement related encounters or
activities and that law enforcement
related encounter activity is further
defined in 105 D1 and specifically
excludes Community caretaking functions
so law enforcement when participating in
town halls or community outreach helping
a child find his parents providing death
notifications dealing with individuals
asking for directions or other
assistance performing inhome or Hospital
well-being checks on the sick elderly or
persons presume missing are not allowed
to record those interactions under
current state law so to answer uh
representative I think it was parr's
question under current law the police
wouldn't be able to record dare classes
or anything like that and that would
actually be
prohibited uh so you have this weird
thing in this bill where if you did pass
this bill fishing game in my opinion
would be
prohibited from videotaping with body
Waring cameras these Hunter Safety
Classes but to the extent they did
they'd have to retain that video for
three years and I certainly think 's you
know we talked a little bit about
privacy but there's a lot of policy
reasons why you may not want a class
recorded in terms of I know I like to
ask dumb questions when I was in school
and I would have probably not done that
had there been someone there with a
video camera saying we're going to
memorialize your stupidity for a number
of years um so I think under the current
statute you'd actually be prohibited
from indiscriminately recording um and
again those are my concerns with the
current bill I don't know if you had
anything to
add good afternoon thank
you the only comments I would add um are
uh you mentioned uh chair Mr chairman
that that um conservation officers uh I
don't think any Court in New Hampshire
would say that a conservation officer is
not a law enforcement officer and I
think that should they elect by internal
policy or by uh subsequent statutory
mandates to have body warant cameras um
rest assured that they are going to have
uh DWIs domestic violence cases uh use
of force issues because they do back up
local law enforcement I think Colonel
Jordan can elaborate more on that than
than I do because uh uh he obviously
knows more about his daily operations
than than than I um my big concern like
attorney Andis as attorney endress
mentioned was the current
recommendations page one line 14 15 16
has no
limitations on privacy absolutely none
and in recent testimony a representative
asked me in one of the other hearings
that without those privacy I'm
paraphrasing our conversation without
those privacy protections would I let uh
would I let a police officer into my
house and I told him absolutely not
because um if you're a benign involve so
someone wrecked a car at the bottom of
your driveway hit your your mailbox and
now the police officer comes up to you
what's your name date of birth phone
number all those personal type of
information and it's raining outside
you're going to invite them in inside to
your house if if for some reason he
continues to record which is a default
setting the entire part of your house
without privacy
protections someone's going to monetize
that someone's going to put it on
Facebook um on in DV cases um uh without
any protections and qualifications for
release of that information to
defendants um you risk having no
protection for a victim of domestic
violence um their their perpetrator
editing that V that that body War camera
m material posting it on YouTube to the
detriment of the domestic violence
victim those are our concerns um those
are addressed in some the other
legislation that's that's currently pen
um so on for those reasons and the ones
mentioned by attorney Andress uh I would
recommend that this bill be uh
inexpedient to legislate and I think
we'll both answer any questions that you
may have
question thank you thank you are there
any questions representative
Harvey so so that's what kind of what I
was alluding to and on a much smaller
basis and corre and I'm going to ask you
my question is please correct me if I'm
wrong one of the things the um you know
the uh Commissioners do is take us all
on field trips I'm very careful not to
put on Facebook or anywhere whe when I'm
not home I don't want them to know that
anyone to know when I'm not home and so
if he were wearing a body camera and
there's Cathy Harvey at the powder mail
Fish Hatchery that could be um that
could be recorded that I'm not home for
that day or or whatever and so that's
what I was alluding to and I didn't do
it well enough but am I correct in it
would certainly memorialize you were
there I don't know that it would sort of
live stream that you weren't home at
that very moment but if someone sought a
copy of that video in the future they
could see where you were at the
time thank you and uh representative
Ford
thank you Mr chairman um you said
something and I I I got caught up on it
which probably I shouldn't have done but
you said um
legally um to the effect of most people
would consider our fish and gang
conservation officers the same as law
enforcement also state trooper local
police and I I I would imagine that the
representative who was sponsoring this
bill thought about that actual phrasing
and being a part of this committee I do
know that conservation officers do
support our state troopers and other
efforts and we definitely need to grow
their budget to make sure they are doing
that safely and with the numbers they
need but I'm just wondering
legally do we do we consider our
conservation officers the same as Law
Enforcement Officers um because I would
imagine that the you sponsor of this
bill Prime sponsor this bill is doing it
because the conservation officers aren't
listed to the general public and
otherwise as law enforcement officers
and so body cameras wouldn't necessarily
be applied to them in the same manner
and and I agree that I think that is
part of the motivation for for the the
bill looking at 105 D1 section five it
defines there sections four and five
defined law enforcement officer and law
enforcement
agency I I didn't write these
definitions and I could be happier with
them if I wrote them myself but a law
enforcement officer means any person
employed by a law enforcement agency I
think that's a a horrible definition but
that's what that's what's written um law
enforcement agency means a state county
municipality Special Districts security
service or police of the College
Community College system of New
Hampshire in the University system of
New Hampshire Security Service of the
legislative or judicial branch Union of
local government Police Department or
any other entity authorized by law to
employ law enforcement off officers or
exercise police Authority Law
Enforcement Officers is also defined in
RSA 106 L2 which is the police standards
and training Council um under 106 L2 a
law enforcement officer is anyone
employed by the state essentially that
has powers of arrest and fits into other
categories so I think without a doubt um
at least in my mind conservation
officers meet the definition of law
enforcement I think for the purposes of
both 105d as well as 106 to they are
certified through police standards and
training Council so I I think they do
meet that definition
already representative pair keep in mind
we're running real late on time yeah
thank you Mr chair um you uh made one
statement that you said uh if if this
were were written you think it do you
think that that statement would uh cover
the intent of this legislation with
without disrupting the existing
legislation to the extent that that we
have been
discussing again I think if you want
fishing game officers to wear bodyw warn
cameras if you put a section in 20626
saying that fishing game are authorized
to to wear bodyw warn cameras or
required to wear body warn cameras or
whatever policy you want to do it would
put fishing game in the same position
following 105 D2 as all local Law
Enforcement Officers as well as the
state police which I assume would um
cover what you essentially want to
cover thank you thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you thank you the chair
now repes uh recognizes Penny Dean
representing herself and you've asked
for 8 to 10
minutes let's hope we can keep it
shorter we are on a hard stop at 4:30 so
that we don't have to call our staff to
go do
overtime
are you guys executing those
today
I hope they're
identical um one is missing the last few
pages they're pated with bait
numbers there's quite a bit of
information um yes
please
my name
is my name is p you can go ahead Penny
oh sorry
my name is Penny
Dean I've lived in New Hampshire since
1995 and I'm an attorney I'm admitted in
Maine New Hampshire
Massachusetts DC circuit all of the
federal courts the First Circuit Court
of Appeals US Supreme Court and I'm a
litigator and I defend Sportsmen on a
regular basis and
unfortunately I defend them usually in
cases where they have been not treated
well by fishing
game and I tell people that I'm not your
typical criminal defense attorney I have
a home office if you tell most criminal
defense attorneys that their clients
would know where they live let alone
have a home office they would have
kittens I let them in my house they're
not criminals they're people charged
with a criminal act but they're not
criminals there's a
difference this bill is sorely needed
and there's a reason for the three-year
attention most violations have a 90day
statute of limitations the fishing game
in many areas is treated special for
three-year statute limitations for many
things and so that is why the reason for
the three-year retention it isn't just
arbitrary I have wanted this bill for
fishing game forever because just like
any law enforcement the truth will stand
when hell's on fire and if you have a
recording you don't have to have a he
said he said we can look at the
recording and see who said what and see
what happened and that's fairness to
people not everybody can afford an
attorney so you see a lot of people
pleading out in fishing game cases
because a lot of them were violations
because they can't afford an attorney
and it breaks my
heart but this case here is more
personal than ever to me I was and I say
was because I'm challenging my hunter
education decertification if you will a
hunter education instructor for 17
years and I love teaching Hunter
education and contrary to what most
people think and I didn't bring the
stats with me so I would have to look at
the stats I can just tell you my classes
the last class that I recall teaching
there's more adults in it than quote
children so when you talk about these
cameras recording people the depending
on the class they're recording a lot of
adults but I think the larger issue here
and what brings me to support this more
than ever I always support it for my
clients but the bottom line
is that these conservation officers they
when they give their one hour Spiel I am
usually the only Hunter education
instructor that stays in the room
usually all the others take a break
because they're quite frankly not
interested I'm very interested because
I'm interested in the law but more
importantly I'm interested because the
vast majority the time there's blood
dripping out of the front of my lips
because I'm biting my tongue because
what these students are being told is
not correct in
law and thereby people who are going to
now you know charge these people these
students and it's going to destroy our
hunting Heritage so the numbers I'd like
you to look at and I didn't wasn't able
to get them printed today I have
printing trouble is the amount of Hunter
education students we pass every year
and the amount of additional hunting
licenses we get and I would say there's
a big drop off and so you ask yourself
why is that if they're motivated enough
to take a hunter education class why
aren't we getting more
hunters and I think that's a good
question I can tell you anecdotal
evidence but it's because of how people
are treated and the things that are said
and the conservation officers when they
are in that one hour with students
absolutely needs to be recorded because
they are telling students policies of
Fish and Game of the law of how they're
going to be treated of what the
consequences are for certain things
those students are relying on that they
see a conservation officer a state
officer police officer in uniform
telling them this is how we interpret
this law this is how we interpret that
law and I'm sure you know because of
your job that when you read the statute
books and the law books there sometimes
as clear as mud and you have to look to
antidotes or legislative history and say
how is this going to be interpreted
what's what's it going to mean what's it
mean and these students are the same and
what brings me here today was a
particular class that I was as I said
all the other instructors almost always
go out I set in and I set in in a class
on lake wiip pasak and what's important
for you to know in how I was treated
because if I've been treated this way
and I'm not a woman that lays down and
gets treated bad without saying I'm
going to stand up for myself how many
other Hunter education instructors have
been treated this way and told to shut
up and stand down and they get the
message and especially women because we
got to know our
place and somehow or other I always
thought my place was in the house and in
the Senate not just the house and so you
have here a class that I was in and I
was an instructor and I'm sitting in the
in the class the only instructor in the
class and the conservation officer is
answering a question from a young lady
probably 30 years old in the front of
the room and he is giving an
interpretation about the 300 foot rule
that's something I've never heard in my
life before I said I'm thinking okay
he's going to tell this person this
they're going to rely on it and every
person I've ever said's got arrested
over it so I'm thinking so my question
is when did Fish and Game Change CH
their interpretation of how they're um
enacting and how they're interpreting
this particular 300t rule of a
building and I guess I asked too many
questions um we have never been told
I've never been told in nowhere in the
rule book that if you're a hunter
education instructor you can't ask
questions of the conservation
officer so I raised my hand standard
thing to do asked a question nobody else
in the class was asking questions other
than this one young lady and I said when
did fishing game change how they
interpret that oh it's always been that
way so I'm thinking well I've been
practicing law for 25 years and it's
absolutely always been opposite of that
so I wait about 10 minutes and I raised
my hand again and I said you know I'm a
lawyer and I practice law and I'm
confused
here and because I'm concerned if again
these students in the class are going to
be listening to this they're going to be
hearing this is how it's interpreted
which is his version was house unlik
winaki if you don't think anybody's
there well it's not a permanently
occupied dwelling you can shoot within
300 feet of it that's not how I've ever
seen it interpreted
before and so I'm concerned about
that well I go to the ladies room and it
like Winn pasak that means there's an
ous out back and I come out back and
that conservation officer is waiting for
me and I wish he would have had video on
there because it's like a bad movie
where I say I'm still trying to figure
out and he gives me three different
stories in five minutes first one was at
it was at some big meeting of
conservation officers I said well when
was the meeting where was it how come I
kind of have my not ear to the ground
why didn't I hear about it then I got a
different story and I and I said well
can you just forward me the email you're
talking about that's private fishing
game information I said you're going to
make me do a right to know if there's
been a policy change
change but the gist of it is this
conservation officer took great umbrage
to this and he made a complaint and what
you have there is really important to
know because again if I am being treated
this way how many others have been and
the other thing is over the years how
many pedophiles or how many people who
are not able to have guns were teaching
these children because they weren't
doing regular checks
my fighting for my certification back
has brought back important things but on
January 5th of 2023 I received a page in
a third letter from the executive
director of fishing game here's what's
important about that it's about a page
and a third it's a very short letter
it's in there for you in the very first
paragraph it says there was an email
from someone at the
class so I said I want to see the email
that's a reasonable question someone
sent an email I'd like to see it very
short letter very few things in
it and when I got all the discovery
first of all for five months they
basically fought and fought and wouldn't
give me the email you know why they
wouldn't give me the email didn't exist
never was
one but here's what's worse about that
if you read all the emails among
themselves the documents that they were
discussing four or five people top level
fishing game
did not list an
email they knew from the beginning there
wasn't an email they had to four or five
people edited this letter over several
weeks going back and forth they're all
copying on it any one of them you would
think in a short page in a third letter
would say wait a minute we're
referencing this email none of us
referred to an email we don't have an
email there must be a mistake and at
some
point when is there incompetence versus
malevolence and I'll let you look at
that paperwork and ask for it because
why didn't when I first asked for it
someone didn't say oh my God we made a
horrible mistake there is no
email and you go through it I've been
litigating and most people consider me a
pretty hard litigator for 25 years and
in three months there's a stack of
papers of of pleadings that I had to
file trying to get documents that I
should have been given freely that's
taller than any sack in any case I've
ever
litigated for 3 to 5 months I basically
couldn't take cases it was a full-time
job and so I'm looking at this and I'm
saying so I said what other Hunter
education instructors have been
dismissed in the past 10
years I still have little faith that
I've been given everything in the truth
I don't know if I have or I haven't but
if you look at the 10 who were who are
the ones who are
dismissed had there been body warn
cameras in my case it would have been
really solved very simple we would have
known who said what when but if you look
at the 10 that were dismissed nine of
them were convicted of crimes or hunting
violations some of which prohibited them
from having guns and they still let them
teach for a couple
years I was pulled immediately my
certification was pulled upon
notice and I believe and still believe
that it's because of my political
activities in the state house and the
fact that I stand up for hunters and and
quite frankly I've won a lot of the
cases but you have to look at this when
conservation officers are interacting
with the public it's no different than
when police officers are interacting
with the public and when they talk about
domestic violence victims those are red
herand those are complaining Witnesses
we don't determine that someone's a
victim until we have a trial till a jury
says they're a victim or a judge says
they're a victim until that they're
complaining witness and he said he said
thing there is not going to be any more
problems with this video than anybody
else's video if you look at the law
enforcement throughout the country
depending on Whose statistics you look
at about 50% of law enforc in this
country now has body warn cameras but
here's what's more important they're
cost effective the University of Chicago
did a wonderful study a couple years ago
and it's in the materials there and
depending on which Economist you you ask
it pays back 5 to one because what you
have when you have body warn cameras is
when you have complaints you don't have
to do giant investigations you download
the body camera and you look at who said
what it saves a lot of complaints it's
transparent and the bottom line is how
many more people have to go through what
I have been through thank you I I get
that point and I I don't think any of
the objection uh that I heard was about
um the value of the
cameras um most of the concern is just
which section of law is this being put
into and uh so if you've got any any
further testimony that's specific to the
body warn cameras as it is in this bill
uh please let us know but we are running
low on time yes sir um I specifically
think that if you look at um lines 14-
16 that says a duplicate copy of the
recording shall be provided in its
entirety to counsel for the defendant or
a proed defendant pursuant to Discovery
request there have been quite a lot of
litigation in this state regarding that
and we have judges thank goodness at
least in the conqur area who say that
law can't Trump the Constitution and
they tell the prosecutors you're either
going to give them the video or you're
going to I'm going to dismiss a case for
failure to give exculpatory evidence
there's no reason that if you're the one
that's on that video that you shouldn't
be able to get a copy of it um and I can
tell you that when law enforcement say
that I have I'm body recording anymore
citizens let them in their house all the
time it's not this big thing like
everybody talks about and they block out
they um do that little blurring like if
a woman didn't wear a blouse or
something they blur that this bill is
needed and it is very carefully crafted
to solve the problem and just like many
police officers wear their body cameras
from start to finish the only time they
don't wear them is in the bathroom in
certain areas like that having
conservation officers wear them to start
to finish is good we need cases where
you have he said he said where the
conservation officers said this man said
this or this man said that they're
confiscating cell phones they're
bullying people they're telling people
if you give us a camera if you give us
your cell phone you get it back tomorrow
or the next day and if you use your
password then you get it back quicker
well I got clients with months and
months and months and they're not giving
them
back and so I think we want honesty and
forthrightness and the bottom line is if
they wear these cameras from start to
finish and their shift like they should
and particularly among our students
we've got to say why are we getting
diminishing numbers in Hunters what's
causing that the next thing we talk
about is the three years I've address
that because the statute of limitations
is different and the other the last last
thing here is that these generally don't
cost as much as you think and so when
they talk about interaction with
Sportsmen that should be on all the time
because that way we'll see in the field
what they're seeing rather than having
them describe it after the fact so I'm
happy to answer practical mechanical
questions but I think that they
shouldn't be exempt they have more
Powers than the state troopers do thank
you yeah does anybody have any
questions
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair uh thanks for taking my question
so if I understood what was previously
said uh the law does not require law
enforcement officials to wear a body
warn camera it does not correct and you
are saying
that fishing under this law fish and gab
would still have that option and you're
saying they should choose to do so
24/7 they should choose to do so when
they are on the clock other words from
the minute they start when they're being
paid when they've got their uniform on
when they're doing what I call the
people's work yes they should because
they take it people lose their hunting
rights they lose their second amendment
rights it's huge um for people that care
about that type of thing and they
sometimes have they forfeit their guns
and ammo and so yes if they're
interacting with the public I think they
should be mandated to do so okay and
followup please follow up so and that
under under d as we've had this
conversation about interactions that
would basically be any any effort that a
COO officer was involved in at all right
which is how a lot of officers do wear
their body cameras but again um they
still assert privacy notices as
necessary so for example if they put in
someone with an iea there's still
competing statutory Authority that says
that would be essentially disclosing
like I said if they come to assist with
an involuntary emergency admission IA
those things are still going to be
um subject to being
withheld thank you thank you any further
questions not seeing any thank you so
much Miss Dean for your testimony today
that was our last uh person is there
somebody else with a card I don't have a
card from you
sir might be in the wrong
pile Colonel Jordan come on up if you
don't have a card we'll give you a card
but uh I don't it here in front of
me so Mr chairman thank you for allowing
me to testify again I'm here to
represent the commission the commission
reviewed this and is opposed to it for a
number of reasons um found it okay thank
you um as far as and I and it's
unfortunate that Penny Dean had this
issue I will tell you that she had an
all day hearing uh it's been adjudicated
and the state prevailed and she did not
and I'm sorry for that but that's was
the fact facts and I'd be happy to
provide you with three ring binders to
show you the evidence in that case it
was quite different from what you were
just told I can assure you um so the
first thing I want to say to you is
that's the wrong reason first of all the
Mandate the conservation officers wear
cameras we'd be the only agency in the
state of New Hampshire mandated to do
that I don't have a problem with cameras
quite frankly if you all remember for 12
Seasons we we took cameras with us on a
daily basis it was called Northwoods law
if and I would encourage anyone if
they're worried about what obervation
officers are doing go watch the show cuz
it shows from Day from the time they get
out of bed in the morning practically
until they go to bed at night and and it
was aired we are only the only law
enforcement agency in the state of New
Hampshire that took that risk I might
add and it was aired across the world
for the world to review and and render
opinions on and it was highly successful
it was highly successful is because
these officers have integrity Beyond
reproach I'd put them up against anyone
in the state
uh they do not do things wrong they do
not do things that are in violations
that's what we have Courts for courts
make those decisions on these cases
there's no unfortunate poor people being
whipped at the post that's just an old
wies tale they get their day in court
just like everybody else does I will say
this one thing the leg with all due
respect one thing the legislature does
to us on a regular basis is they mandate
certain functions you do it with All
State agencies the problem with New
Hampshire fishing game is we are a
self-funded a agency self-funded there
is no other law enforcement agency in
the state of New Hampshire funded by
user fees none they all receive taxpayer
dollars either in general funds or or uh
other and a lot of other states Wildlife
agencies in fact where we got the fiscal
node information from other agencies
that are wearing these cameras are all
funded by taxpayer money I don't have a
problem wearing a camera I'll strap a
camera on All 48 of these people what I
do have a problem with is I don't have
the money to pay for it Colonel Jordan
that was part of the fiscal note it was
going to go and give you funds we
weren't going to ask you to do it
without paying for those cameras so but
it the funding has to be a constant
funding okay it has to be something that
isn't a matching Grant a matching Grant
is going to require us to come up with
the money we can't do that now and and
frankly if there's a taste in the state
to produce
$200,000 let me make a couple of
suggestions to you one is fund search
and rescue that hasn't been done in over
20 years I've been coming to this body
for 20 years asking for search and
rescue to be funded that saves lives it
has nothing to do with a courtroom
prosecution it's got nothing to do with
Miss Dean it saves lives let's fund that
let's spend the money so that I can get
them better equipped to go above Tree
Line like they did last week in 80 mph
winds to bring that poor soul down we've
never done that let's attach that to
this bill and go to Fisco with it I I'm
all about that I've been trying to do it
for 15 years we could put on more
conservations officer two other
conservation officer could be hired and
equipped for this kind of
money that this is a waste of money a
complete waste of money and it
frustrates me because there are so many
other things that we could do for the
citizens of our state if you if you're
willing to spend that money let's do it
but let's do it on something that's
going to make a difference for everybody
in the state all the citizens of the
state not the cam not the cameras go to
Northwoods law if you want to see what
we did we did it every day for years and
I don't have a problem with it we put it
on prime time as I as I said we're the
only ones that ever did that but let's
not waste this money on on cameras
because one person in the state feels
that she was wronged and it's necessary
that's nonsense spend it on something
that's going to help our citizens help
our Sportsman I've never we just
finished two rounds of banial hearings
where people put up uh suggestions and
ideas to no Hampshire fishing game on
things to change I have never once never
once heard from a sportsman or woman
that has asked for a body War camera
I've heard him ask for better management
of our Wildlife Resources more purchase
of habitats and lands more officers out
in the field to do their job let's fund
search and rescue so I don't have to pay
for it with my hunting dollars anymore I
get asked that daily I've never been
asked for a body camera I don't think
there's a desire for that from our users
who are paying the bills I think we
ought to listen to that I'd ask you to
to join me in saying no to this it's
ridiculous it's unnecessary and it's a
waste of a lot of money thank you very
much thank you Colonel any questions
one question uh representative
goalie thank you Colonel for taking my
question and I for one have
always reached out for more funding for
yes you have search and rescue but I'm
looking at the fiscal note and I I just
look at on the backs of sports men and
women in this
state to have to take out of the
department another looking at the fiscal
note between 102 and 117,000
out of the funds that are already thin I
mean would this mean cutting somewhere
else oh it's absolutely going to mean
cutting it it attorney helison from
Marat County by the way I didn't call
him he reached out to me because he was
concerned about the cost of this he
indicated to me that those figures are
probably low based on his experiences
and so uh all the agencies that are
doing this are telling me that they're
hiring Personnel to manage these things
I don't have a problem again again I
have no problem with doing any of this
if I have all of my very long needs
fulfilled that we've been asking for for
years if I'm going to hire another
person I'd rather put him in a costume
like this and put him out in the field
that's where I need him I don't need him
managing a camera business I need him
out in the field um so yes you would
have you're going to we're going to end
up losing or cutting uh probably
Personnel if I got to pay that so I'm
not sure how all will be will stand in
violation of it cuz I there's just no
money to do it there's just no money to
do it
it thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you sir and we got a late card coming in
Kevin Glenn you're
recognized you have two minutes let's
keep it to two minutes because we're
supposed to still do some exac and we
have to be out at 4:30 or sooner all
right someone start the clock thank you
very much I've actually never even been
in this building before uh I'm just here
shooting a video
for Penny uh just as a favor but I got
to tell you I my eyes are wide open you
guys do phenomenal stuff here I couldn't
do what you do so thank you for doing
that um I I am a resident of Bedford
going on eight years um my family and I
live there 12-year-old daughter and I'm
a big supporter of um the police I'm a
committee down there to uh create a new
uh police
department what concerns me what I hear
today and I wasn't planning on speaking
is that I feel like there's a lot of
things being said almost fear being
whipped up in this room about something
that's been around body warn cameras
have been around for a long time it's
nothing new and I know that there's
probably people on both sides of this
table that have their feelings one way
or the other but I guess my question
comes down
to what are we
hiding the the funding of it is going to
be a separate discussion if I understand
that correctly right that's not being
decided today so why don't we give that
a
chance to be funded let's decide on
whether or not we actually need it and
and I believe greater accountability we
live in a very litigious world and
things are happening all the time you
see it on the
news and this is a chance to go okay
we're being transparent with what we're
doing and I don't think there's anything
wrong with that and I think a lot of
American people support it thank you
very much and thank you for what you do
thank you
sir I'm afraid we do not have any more
time
today we've let everybody have one time
to talk you can submit any further
correspondence to the committee by email
and or um through the the website until
midnight tonight thank you I will
absolutely we we don't want to shut any
further communication down but this time
we need to also end the hearing on the
bill um and with that and not seeing
anyone else I'm going to close the
public hearing on
15:30 at this time we're going to take a
break for uh about 4 minutes to allow
people to caucus and use the restroom
and we'll come back and see if we want
to exec any of these that we've heard
today
executive session is open for Bill
and I'm going to look to representative
ulette for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion of ought to pass on Bill HB
11116 do we have a second I will second
that Mr chair all right it's been moved
and seconded is there any
discussion representative Harvey I see
you reaching for your
microphone let's try to keep the
discussions short though because we know
that we are running running low low on
time and I know people wanted to get out
this will be one sentence I will be
voting against this because it is not
supported by fish and game thank you
thank
you anybody else any further discussion
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
um I appreciate the amendment that uh
takes out the um the 38 um from the
definition um I'm I'm personally
concerned about the any any uh action or
the remove removal of the lever action
carbine because I think that it opens
the uh doors to um to people walking
around with ARs in um the backyards of
people in pelum and Hudson um and even
Nash um because many I think some of
these calibers um uh support uppers on a
rifles thank
you thank
you any other discussion was that the
motion on the amendment or that was the
original OTP to be able to talk about
the amendment we have to do the
OTP okay and now uh with that discussion
I'm going to offer
Amendment what's the number on that
one Amendment
H and would somebody second my offering
of that Amendment I'll second that Mr
chair okay uh I'm going to discuss my
Amendment uh as representative Darby
mentioned this amendment just simply
strikes the 38 from in front of the 357
which uh clarifies everything to make it
much nicer and uh there's no ambiguity
on the 38 uh originally it was put in
simply because I told OS that the gun is
a
38357 CU I've grown up knowing you can
shoot 38s or 357 through the same gun
and they put the 38 in there so uh we
took it back out and so I think it's a
much better bill without uh with that
Amendment without the 38 in front of it
and I had asked for everyone to support
that and uh that's the end of my
discussion is there any other discussion
on that
Amendment seeing none will the clerk
call the role on ought to pass as
amended we got to pass the amendment oh
call yeah will the C call the role on
the amendment thank you yes I'm calling
the role on amendment 0349 I think
that's the number yes yes uh
representative goalie
yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
kofalt yes representative Mooney yes
representative Brown yes representative
corkran if I got that wrong dabson
right sorry representative McDonald yes
representative
Willette yes representative AAR yes
represent Harvey yes representative Reed
is
absent representative elberger yes
representative wait a minute I got that
wrong give me a
second
Ford yes representative Morton yes
representative Paige yes representative
peer yes representative Rosner is absent
and representative Derby yes and me and
the chair yes and I didn't do my correct
one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
y0 will the clerk call the RO on otpa
please oh all right who's making the
motion otpa Mike you were doing that
Mike take a motion from you yes I move
to uh otpa
1116 and second I'll second that Mr
chair thank you moved and seconded any
further discussion on otpa now that
we've passed the
amendment seeing none clerk can call the
role on otpa
please representative
goalie yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
Co F yes representative
Moody yes representative Brown yes
representative
corkman
absent representative McDonald yes
representative
wette yes representative AAR yes
Harvey
no representative Reed absent
representative Ford
yes representative ilber
no representative Morton no
representative Paige
no representative PE
no representative Rosner is absent and
representative Darby no excuse me sorry
no no thank
you uh I have 10 y you missed me and
this jeez keep forgetting about you
representative the chairman yes okay
that would be
11 that gives us 11 Ys six Nays okay I'm
going to need a uh
written statement from the minority if
you're going to make one representative
Darby is going to write
that uh it's not typical for the
substitute to write I I'm not a
substitute actually oh I'm I'm a member
of this you're a new permanent
now okay I thought you were just
substituting for Ben Ming I forgot you
you got Ben Ming went to another
committee that's right okay
yes
and Michael uh will you write a blurb
for the majority please absolutely all
right that's taken care of
um that ends exec session on 1116 we're
going to open up exec session on
1077 do we have a
motion uh
mikette
I make the motion of ought to pass
excuse
me read the right
line I'm sorry which oh you were
supposed to make that motion rep Smith
yes thank you Mr chair I make a motion
to itl Bill
1077 okay thank you and Mike you were
supposed to second that one I got
confused on that one sorry I'm sorry I
second that okay it's been moved and
seconded any discussion on itl for this
all right seeing
none let's take the role on on the itl
please representative goalie
yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
kofalt yes representative Mooney
yes representative Brown yes
representative corkran
absent representative McDonald
yes representative wet yes
representative abar yes representative
Harvey
yes representative Reed is
absent representative Ford
yes representative elberger
yes representative Morton yes
representative Paige yes representative
PE yes representative Rosner is absent
representative Derby
yes rep then chairman
Spain yes this is 17 yay z
a consent 17 or
18 seven 17 okay so was that the other
one 11 to6 or was it okay I thought it
was 11 to 7 no it was 11 to six consent
okay with everybody all right that'll go
on
consent and
uh Jonathan you want to write up a yes
report thanks if these reports can be
given to me uh by the end of the night
tonight that'd be great uh I'm supposed
to ask before you leave for today but
we're right up on the deadline and I'm
not going to do that to you excuse me Mr
chair do you need a uh write up for a
consent we do write up for consent
anyway in case it gets pulled from
consent okay thank you
but we only take one because there's no
minority that closes the hearing on the
exec on
1077 I'm going to open the exec on
and representative oulette I know this
is the one that you're supposed to
do
okay you had the right one last time I
make the motion I ought to pass thank
you is there a second I'll second that
Mr chair it's been moved and seconded
I'm going to present an amendment on
that one it's
0350 and again this is just taking 38
off of the list so that it's a 357 only
and I'd like uh to have a second on my
Amendment if I could I'll second Mr
chair thank you and is there a
discussion on my Amendment
anybody
well it can usually depend on you to
have something to
say all right no discussion on that
let's go ahead and take the role on the
amendment please you guys are F I'm
trying to because we've only gotten till
4:30 and then we go into overtime and I
get in trouble representative
goalie
yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
Kofa yes representative Mooney yes
representative Brown yes representative
McDonald yes representative
Willette yes representative a yes
representative Harvey
yes representative Ford yes
representative elberger yes
representative Morton yes representative
Paige yes representative peir yes
representative Derby yes 16 is a zero
you got for that
me chairman pain
yes
17 okay we now have the amendment passed
uh we're on otpa if somebody wants to
make a motion here um representative
ulette I make the motion we pass HB 1424
with Amendment otpa yes I'll second Mr
chair representative Smith seconds we
are on otpa discussion please
anybody seeing none the clerk will call
the role on otpa for
1424 representative
goalie yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
kofol yes representative Mooney yes
representative Brown yes representative
McDonald yes representative wette yes
representative AAR yes resentative
Harvey yes representative Ford yes
representative elberger yes
representative
Morton yes representative Paige yes
representative PE yes representative
Derby yes chairman Blain yes
that okay I'll write that
one
that closes the exact on 1424 I'm going
to open the exact now on
1024 and I'll entertain a motion
representative KH thank you
mrman thank you Mr chairman after
hearing all those testimony it seems
like that it need to have further study
therefore I make a motion that we do the
further study for this bill inter
studies move we have a do we have a
second on the interim study I will
second moved and
seconded uh any discussion on interim
study everybody seems aligned on that uh
let's go ahead and call the role Mr
clerk all
right representative
goalie yes representative KH yes
representative Smith yes representative
kofalt yes representative
tutor uh hang on let me see my list here
Mooney yes representative Brown
yes uh rep representative McDonald yes
representative
wette yes representative abar yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Ford yes representative uh elberger yes
representative Morton yes representative
Paige yes representative peir
yes representative Derby yes chairman
Spain yes again we're are 17 and
zero
consent all
right that
closes that closes the uh exec session
on 1024 I'm going to open the exec
session on
1228 Mr chairman I make a motion to itl
hb1
1228 do we have a
second
second it's been moved and
seconded uh any discussion on the
itl representative abar thank you Mr
chairman I believe putting a law on the
books to deal with with what should be a
management issue such as alternative
testing and strong recommendations to
fish and game to go to commissioner edel
blute for alternative teaching methods
thank
you any other discussion on the
bill all right clerk may call the
rooll representative
goalie yes representative Khan yes
representative Smith no
Representative kofalt
no representative Mooney
yes representative Brown yes
representative uh McDonald
yes representative wette yes
representative AAR yes representative
Harvey yes representative Ford yes
representative elberger
yes representative Morton yes
representative Paige yes representative
PE
yes H representative Darby
yes and me chairman
Spain
yes
okay 15-
two yes thank you it's 15 to2 does
anybody uh care if we put it on
consent I'm going to look directly at
the two who said no all right uh and who
wants to write a consent blur for that
let me see uh I'll figure that out later
that ends the hearing on
12:28 uh that is the last one we're
going to take up today we're right on
4:30 and so I appreciate everybody
coming in and dealing with a long
painful day uh we meet again on February
6th and instead of 10 which is what we
were all expecting you'll notice that
when we had to postpone the other one
today I scheduled that for 9:30 so let's
count on 9:30 on February 6th we had to
move that to a date and time certain and
that was the only time I could be
certain of because we won't have started
all the other bills for the
day uh does anybody else have any other
issues before we adjourn for the
day okay have yourself a great
night